Four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're live.
Hello Denis.
Hi Joe.
Great to see you.
Great to be here.
As always.
It's great to be here.
So tell me about this,
these cards that you gave me and what
this is all about.
Okay.
Well,
this is an interesting project.
This is about the RV hereclitis,
which was a,
which was associated with the Institute
for Ecotechnics,
which is try to keep this close to your
face.
Okay.
There you go.
Further,
uh,
associated with,
you know,
how do I explain it?
It was actually a theater company called
the theater of all possibilities,
but the institute for Ecotechnics was
started in the early seventies.
They built the ship,
this,
uh,
Chinese junk essentially with a feral
concrete hall.
And my connection was they have Cruz
Cruz,
the world essentially since 1973 looking
into different things relevant to global
ecology.
They've done sampling in the Antarctic
can in 1981.
They decided to go to the Amazon and I
was doing my graduate work in Ketosis at
that time.
So that was my connection with the
Institute of Ecotechnics and uh,
you know,
at the time I thought these people are
nuts.
I mean they were kind of nuts and they
were very naive about what they were
doing as far as doing ethno botanical
work.
Not that I wasn't naive about it at the
time,
but I had a better handle on it than
they do anyway.
That was the original connection and the
same group years after I had more or
less a,
you know,
kind of severed.
I didn't really sever my relationship
but I kind of distanced myself from
them.
But then that same group went on in the
eighties to build biosphere two,
which you probably heard of.
They had financing for biosphere two.
So they've gone to a whole other level
of ambition and,
and madness.
But um,
and biosphere two went off traveling
that to people who don't know what we're
talking about.
Biosphere two was the idea of building a
terrestrial environment that was
completely shut off from everything.
And that was self sustaining.
And it was a huge complex.
It was a big series of domes really.
Each dome replicated some earthly bio,
like the desert,
the rain forest,
the ocean,
and so on.
And the idea was that,
uh,
it was a,
it was a dry run for building a Mars
colony,
you know,
or some planetary colony.
And the idea was Mars and they put
people into this environment for like
two years at a
to see if they could make it work,
if they could really have a balanced
ecosystem.
Well,
as it turned out,
it didn't work so well,
but they learned a great deal from this.
And they also got a lot of adverse
publicity because I think the,
uh,
I think the science establishment in a
way became kind of jealous and you know,
like these people,
they don't know anything about what
they're doing.
They got $600,
million dollars to build this.
What the hell?
So I got a lot of criticism,
but the fact is a lot of good science
came out of this and they're still
going.
And the interesting thing is they've had
their fingers in many pies.
You know,
they have a gallery in a hotel in London
called the opto October gallery.
I always stay there,
a fund in London,
they have a publishing company,
the synergetic press based in Santa Fe.
That's who published this book
ultimately.
So it's kind of like 30 years later what
goes around comes around in the book is
Ethno pharmacologic search for
psychoactive drugs and it's from.
It's labeled from 1967 to 2017.
Right.
And the.
And the story behind this is,
I'm just too,
but just to complete the hereclitis
story a minute.
So the hereclitis has been plying the
ocean more or less continuously since
1973 and they are now renovated the ship
because you know it needs it,
it needs a new hole and all that.
So they're trying to raise funds
obviously for that.
But it's just a very interesting story
about people that are passionate about
the ecology,
about the earth and about science.
Don't know a whole lot about any of it,
but their passion drove them forward and
and their passion.
Particularly the founder,
a guy named John Allen who's now,
I think he's in his eight.
He isn't his eighties,
but he was the visionary behind it.
And without knowing a whole lot,
they just went ahead and did it,
you know,
so in that spirit,
you have to hand it to them and they
have,
they've done incredible things over that
period of time.
And so it's a,
it's a great story and it's worth the
attention and you know,
it's up to you.
I mean,
it's of,
it's up to you if you want to bring her
on or somebody.
But it's,
it's,
it sounds fascinating,
really romantic,
you know,
this escience in,
in the true spirit of discovery,
you know,
and what are they done by amateurs,
right?
It isn't,
is fascinating.
Were they trying to do,
and we're kind of research at her that
they're trying to do in the ocean.
All kinds of things.
They've been sampling coral reefs.
They'd been sampling,
uh,
looking at,
you know,
uh,
global warming in both the Arctic and
the Antarctic.
Uh,
they of in [inaudible] 81,
they wanted to do ethnobotany and the
Amazon and,
and they had shelties on their board of
directors and the director of the
expedition was Wade Davis and,
and I was doing my graduate work at that
time and we knew they were coming.
So as a result of that I was able to
join the expedition and we deny at the
time he was selected by them as the
chief science officer and when,
by the time I got there he was getting a
little disillusioned with them,
you know,
and the,
the,
I guess you could say the personal
dynamic was kind of strange.
And like if you read my book,
the Brotherhood of the screaming abyss,
there's a couple of chapter,
there's a chapter on this,
but over time even weighed,
changed his mind and,
and I,
I now get the larger picture of what
they were trying to do.
And you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a real story.
I mean,
these people didn't recognize
boundaries.
That's the thing.
And they,
because they were theater people,
they actually understood,
which I didn't at the time that what
they were doing and their whole effort
was really a performance,
you know,
on a global level.
They did all these things kind of
realizing that this was the theater of
all possibilities and they had a theater
in Austin,
Texas by that name.
So I could.
It's a wild story.
It sounds like a freaky crew.
It's a freaky crew.
And that was the point.
Well,
some of the people that were on that
1981 expedition or now,
um,
they're still associated with it.
So it has some longevity.
Others have passed on,
others have left in disgust or,
or they,
they have enough.
But I was able to reconnect with the
people that run,
you know,
they have this ranch in Santa fe called
the Synergia ranch.
And one of the things that's based there
is this press,
the synergetic press.
So when I was doing this project with
the book I was casting around for who's
going to publish this after we do it,
and they stepped up and they publish a
lot of psychedelic stuff.
They have a book called the mystic
chemist about Albert Hoffman.
Uh,
they republishes,
uh,
the IOWASCA reader,
which,
uh,
originally Eduardo Luna and Steven
Dwight had published.
Well,
they expanded that and they published
status,
a very beautiful,
you know,
a Redo,
essentially a second edition.
Very nice work.
Then I'm Don Latin,
uh,
who's not that well known,
but he's written several books about the
history of psychedelics and the people
involved.
And he wrote a book that they published
called changing our minds.
Ironically,
about the same time,
Michael Pollan brought his book out.
So Michael Pollan been who he is,
got all the attention.
Dawn's got very little,
still a good book,
you know,
so they're good people.
I've decided that some of my initial
judgments,
not knowing the people and when I just
sort of walked into their reality in a
ketose when I got there,
you know,
which they never bothered to,
to explain.
It's like,
you know,
they never said,
oh,
well,
you know,
we're acting funny because we do things
differently than you do,
you know.
And I was like,
what?
Well,
I'm sure they evolve to,
we were talking about they have,
they have evolved and they learn a lot
through this biosphere two a,
you know,
project which was a real lesson to
everybody.
Um,
but anyways,
so because they still existed and really
because of the,
of the resurrection of the Iowasca
reader that had been my recent contact
with them.
So when I decided to do this book,
I thought they were a good candidate to
publish this book.
And they totally got it.
They took it on.
They've done an amazing job and this
book or these,
this set,
as you know,
you know,
the genesis of it because you had a lot
to do with it when we were,
when I was here last year,
you know,
in,
um,
the backstory is in 1967,
the US government,
the National Institute of Mental Health
of all people put together a conference
in San Francisco in 67 called the f no
pharmacologic search for psychoactive
drugs.
And nobody noticed.
It was a private conference.
It was not open to the public.
The only thing that public ever got out
of it was the symposium proceedings,
which is the first book there.
And uh,
I was very heavily influenced by that
book because somehow or other it came
into my hands at age 17,
you know,
bored teenager living in peo onion,
Colorado,
wishing that I was with my brother in
Berkeley where all the action was at the
time.
And I'm like,
what is this book,
you know?
So I totally,
I devoured it.
And about the same time I discovered the
teachings of Don Juan,
which my brother gave to me for my 18th
birthday.
And although much in there is probably
fiction,
those two books gave me a complimentary
perspective.
The teachings of Don Juan was the
ethnographic lens through which you
could use look at the use of
psychedelics and,
and which I kind of filled in those
spaces.
Then this book came out and it was like
at.
I knew who she was.
I knew who a few of these people were at
the time,
shelties and Shogun and Andrew while
we're actually on the original faculty.
And uh,
so when the book fell into my hands at
age 17,
I was very excited and I read the whole
thing.
And,
and this is what really helped me focus
my career.
It made me aware that maybe I could make
a career out of ethno pharmacology,
you know.
And,
and in my very naive 17 year old teenage
brain,
I thought,
wow man,
I can get paid to get stone was in part
that.
But,
uh,
you know,
there was more to it.
But that's what led me to,
to pursue that career.
And so this book has always loomed large
in my sort of Pantheon.
Originally there was supposed to be
followup conferences for this,
for the government to have every 10
years.
Well,
the war on drugs,
scotched,
all that.
They became embarrassed that they had
anything to do with a conference like
this.
What was the goal of the conference?
Is that clear of the original
conference?
Oh,
for people to kind of report on their
work.
Um,
and sort of mark the state of the art
in,
in psycho ethno pharmacology at the
time.
So the first book was really where
things like the snuffs and I was and uh,
uh,
you know,
and other things that we don't think of
really a psychedelics like Kava and
nominated miscarrying all.
When you're saying the snaps,
do you mean like some of the more
psychedelics psychedelics?
What is it called?
The a hey as that one that's an orally
active form that.
But yeah,
for Rola and then,
and them Thera,
which is uh,
uh,
the,
what are they called?
Yotpo?
I think there was some easily they,
they stuff them up their nose.
Is that the dental or that's the deal?
Yeah.
And this is the first book.
The 67 book was the first one where,
you know,
there was a collection of the leading
experts of the time,
most of whom you've never heard of.
But there were,
there were iconic people like shelties,
Andrew Weil,
Sheboygan.
Another interesting fellow,
uh,
many interesting people.
One of the most interesting in the first
conference was a gentleman named Steven
Zahra,
a Hungarian,
a chemist and psychiatrist and
pharmacologist and a,
he originally worked in Budapest and uh,
and eventually he moved to the states
and became pretty high up in the
National Institutes of health.
He was the director of the National
Institute on Drug Abuse in the late
fifties.
But the interesting thing is before
that,
um,
and he was just a researcher in,
at a hospital in,
in Budapest,
he applied to Santos to get lsd.
He wanted to do research with LSD.
They refuse to give it to him because he
was behind the iron curtain.
So he,
so he synthesize dmt being a chemist and
he had to determine if it was actually a
psychedelic.
So it when the grand tradition he did
that by self injecting himself,
you know,
so he's a true pioneer and I invited him
to the conference.
So he's the first person to definitively
show that the emt was a psychedelic.
He's now 95.
He's in great shape.
I invited him to the conference,
but he said,
well,
I'm 95,
I don't go anywhere anymore.
But he submitted a very nice video
introduction to it.
And the other interesting thing that he
did after the 67 conference,
he,
he's,
he was thinking,
well,
what's going on and will,
what is it with the hippies and all the
psychedelics.
And,
and uh,
so his supervisor said,
well Steve,
why don't you go over to Haight Ashbury
and hang out for awhile?
So he did.
And he submitted a paper called the
scientist among the hippies and they
wouldn't let him publish.
They said,
you can't publish this.
So it sat in his drawer for 50 years.
When this book came along,
he said,
I have something.
I'll submit here,
I don't care if they,
you know,
it's,
it doesn't matter anymore.
So one of the papers in this second
volume is his original 67 paper.
Oh Wow.
And then,
so the second volume is kind of,
you know,
because the government didn't step up to
the plate,
like they said they would.
Um,
there was no followup conferences.
and I've for a long time I wanted to do
a followup conference.
I wanted to do it on the 30th
anniversary.
90 seven never happened.
Time passes.
So 2017 was the 50th anniversary.
It all fell together.
All of a sudden,
you know,
I found a venue in the UK,
a beautiful country house that was a
called tearing him hauled that was run
by one of our friends who shares,
you know,
our perspective.
He made that available.
We put the word out,
we got support to produce the
conference.
So we brought about 16 people,
um,
you know,
to tearing ham and the England and spent
three days presenting.
And those videos are all up on the web.
I'll send you the link.
That's open access.
The other thing that we couldn't do at
67 that we did in 2017,
there was no facebook live streaming
will.
All our videos were facebook live
straight.
We had 60,000
people watching these lectures at some
points,
you know,
I mean,
so that's amazing.
That's incredible.
And that created excitement and then we
basically paid for the book by
preselling Greece selling that.
And a lot of people stepped up and
order.
A lot of people were very patient
because I was,
you know,
I was,
I thought,
oh,
this will be out by Christmas,
right?
Well,
no,
it's a big project.
So it took six months longer than I
thought.
Um,
but now it's out there and uh,
hopefully it'll be a,
a landmark in the field,
like the first one was.
And,
and what we wanted to do to honor the
first one was reprint the first one
along.
So that's why it's two books.
We did a high resolution,
a scam of the original book and
reprinted that one.
And then make you think like,
imagine if Nixon wasn't president back
then.
What could have been done?
Like what if they didn't have that
sweeping 1970 psychedelic act where they
made everything illegal?
Like what if they continued with this
stuff and who knows where we'd be today.
We,
yeah,
we could ask that question about a lot
of things.
What if that didn't happen?
Like the psychedelic research that's
happening now,
that's,
it's taken 40 years to get back to it.
And basically the psychedelic research
is,
is a lot of the same thing was going
back,
going on back in the even late fifties
and sixties.
What's going on now is they're repeating
a lot of that,
but with more rigorous experimental
design with,
with better controls and all that.
But it's the same stuff,
you know,
which is wonderful.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm all for it.
Um,
to see this work done.
I also have plenty to say about the
limitations of that strictly clinical,
uh,
you know,
a sort of medical approach.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
organizations like maps and hefter half
to work within the constraints of what's
possible.
But I think in some ways they,
they force themselves to,
they're forced to put on blinders in a
certain way to what else is possible,
for example,
the way that a Iowasca has been sort of
marginalized and there is research going
on about it,
but there's nothing approved in the
states.
Uh,
and I think it's important to pursue
that work,
but because you can't synthesize Iowasca
like you can silicide bonaire Mtma or
these things that under clinical trials,
it's much more difficult to study within
the constraints of a phase one clinical
trial.
But in fact Iowasca is touching and I
think far more lives than say,
well,
I can't say about mushrooms because
mushrooms are a lot out there.
But you know,
the potential,
the impact that it's having on society
is much greater because people are
rediscovering this and people are,
I think reaching out for.
They're reaching out for anything that,
that will work.
You know,
as a society,
we are spiritually bereft and I think
there's a pervasive sense of despair and
a feeling of,
what would you call it,
spiritual impoverishment or something.
As we see that all of our institutions
are becoming,
you know,
we're,
we're seeing behind the curtain,
I'm realizing that there are empty,
you know,
they don't really have anything to offer
on the spiritual level,
especially religions.
People are rejecting religions as the
sort of,
you know,
Shell game that it is empty promises
that don't deliver and I think that's a
lot of why people are reaching out for
these plant medicines,
you know,
and uh,
going to South America or to have
Iowasca or,
or finding them in their own community
because people crave spiritually
meaningful experiences and,
and our
cultured needs it more than effort.
Well,
the thing about psychedelics that,
what you just said is so important that
they deliver.
They deliver.
If you're skeptical about religion and
you know there's some people that get a
lot out of religion,
that's fine,
but if you're,
you're skeptical about it,
it's not going to fulfill your promises.
It's not,
it's not going to see.
It's not going to give you anything that
you can say,
oh my God,
this is irrefutable.
Psychedelic experiences are pretty
irrefutable that something's happening.
That's titanic.
It's just,
it's so immense and bizarre and beyond
the normal that it's hard to just
dismiss it and the only people that
really do dismiss it,
the people that haven't experienced it.
Exactly.
You know,
I mean,
I,
I sometimes say psychedelics are the
antidote to faith.
You know,
you don't need faith to take a
psychedelic.
What you need is courage,
you know,
religions offer faith,
which is basically saying,
here's a list of things that you need to
believe without question and if that's
your inclination,
fine.
But most of us are more skeptical.
We need something tangible,
something more tangible.
So I think faith is a mean.
That's how religions entice you to
believe.
But I think that,
uh,
in a way it's deceptive.
Why do you have to believe when you can,
in that intensely personal encounter
between you and a plant teacher or you
and a plant molecule and a molecule you
can experience for yourself.
You don't need faith.
You can say,
I know that this exists and the,
the realms that it opens up for you real
because I've experienced it.
Um,
and you know,
I think faith,
I think that,
uh,
we in a way,
you know,
at least the Abrahamic religions,
Christianity and Judaism and Islam to a
certain extent have poisoned the western
mind,
you know,
and,
and encouraged our separation from
nature and basically propagated this
idea that we're separated from nature
and we own it and we,
we have every right to dominate it.
And we're seeing the consequences of
that.
You know,
we have to rediscover this indigenous
perspective that we are part of nature.
We're properly in properly frame.
We should be symbiotic with nature.
It's all about symbiosis.
It's all about collaborating with the
global community of species to advance
consciousness,
not just of our species,
but of the whole community of sentience
species.
This is what the psychedelics can do.
And I think this is what the
psychedelics are desperately reaching
out to our species.
And you know,
anybody who watches my podcast or
listens to me is this is my wrap.
Wake up you monkeys.
You know,
you're wrecking this place.
It's that simple.
You're recognized place and that's
because you have to really understand
your relationship to nature.
Realize that number one,
you monkeys aren't running things,
the plants are running things basically
because they're sustaining life on
earth.
Other things are,
you know,
that's part of it.
And then once you wake up to the fact
that,
you know,
we're,
we're in a participatory,
collaborative role with the community of
species,
then we have to change a whole lot of
things that we're not doing right now
because we're certainly not,
you know,
developing sustainable ways to live on a
global scale and,
and we're seeing the consequences of
this.
Now.
What's dismaying besides the fact that
it's happening,
is that there is so much denial,
so much refusal to recognize this on the
part of the people that supposedly are,
are running the show,
you know,
and they're,
they're willfully ignorant and this is a
problem.
So,
you know,
um,
I think a lot of people will agree with
me.
A lot of people who listen to this show
will agree with me when I say I've
pretty much given up on politics.
Politics seems to me irrevocably broken.
Many other institutions are
dysfunctional,
if not broken.
I mean sciences corrupt in government is
corrupt.
It's corporate,
the corporatism is,
you know,
these are all flawed systems because
they're not,
they don't have a base of compassion and
recognition of the interrelatedness of
all things and psychedelics are a
catalyst for waking up and so once
people have that experience,
then their perspective has changed and
if they were influential,
they can go out and make change on a
global scale.
I think it's so important that Michael
Poem put out that book because the guy
who's a mainstream straight laced guy
who's written about architecture and
agriculture and all these different
things where people like really respect
his opinions and his word.
Yeah,
this guy has not just written this book
but has also gone out in a limb and had
a bunch of different psychedelic
experiences in controlled settings.
Right.
And talks about them and the profound
impact that it had on his at one point,
skeptical mind.
He was very skeptical about what these
things were.
Yale though,
I love Michael Pollan.
I have for a long time.
Um.
Oh,
sorry.
You just don't want any angry.
You know,
I've,
I've loved his work for a long time and
I'm really delighted that he's come out
and written about this.
There are some things about his book.
I have to say that I'm a little
disappointed,
but then I also have to say I'm only
about a little over halfway through.
It was disappointing.
Well,
so far he hasn't really emphasized or
set much about.
He sort of writes it from the
perspective that all of this started
with the discovery of Lsd in 1943 and
then that was the psychedelic era there.
Their indigenous traditions,
thousands of years old you shouldn't
talk to.
You hasn't really talked about those
things.
Well,
he knows they exist.
Did he talk to you at all?
He did.
Not as ridiculous.
How dare I was also,
of course,
extremely jealous and angry and upset
that he didn't talk to me.
I mean,
what the hell,
you know,
but you've been banging at the bushes
for 60 years now.
Yeah.
Well come on man.
Seriously.
Um,
I'm not shower.
Why he did that?
If that was a conscious decision,
but I'm kind of disappointed because I
think I have a perspective that,
that,
uh,
you know,
I have some things to say that so far
haven't been said in this book and
things that Michael Pollan would,
would completely relate to.
You know,
he's the one that brought up the idea
that,
you know,
with respect to like plant domestication
and on our relationship with our food
plants,
you know,
we think we're growing.
We're cultivating plants.
Actually plants are cold fading us,
you know,
this is plants program for world
domination,
right?
The same is true of all these teacher
plants.
This is why they're out there,
you know,
on the global stage now and he didn't.
Maybe he will get to it.
I mean,
I'm only mildly jealous.
I wish he had talked to me on the other
him.
What he has written is going to be
important.
It's going to be influential.
I mean,
this will be influential to a small
number of people.
Pollin's book is going to bring it to
the attention of millions.
It's going to open people's eyes and and
refresh the way people view this whole
subject.
I think when you.
When you look at when you're talking
about ancient cultures and the use of
psychedelics going back thousands and
thousands of years and then this dip
somewhere around 1970 where it almost
seems to have gotten down to a very low
hum,
but now the drums are beating again.
Coming back.
Now it's coming back.
Know.
I'm really fascinated and excited by
that because I think this is me too.
I don't think it's the answer to
everything,
but I think it's the glue.
I think it's there's,
there's a thing about the psychedelic
experience that forces you to recognize
that you have these pre established
ideas of what things are and that you've
kind of put them in these boxes and
you've sort of pushed it away and he was
like,
well,
I've defined what a city is and I'm just
gonna put that over there.
Now I know what that is.
I'm not going to think about that
anymore.
I've defined what a road is.
I've defined me.
I remember after one of my first dmt
experiences just sitting around looking
at roads differently like I was,
I was on a road.
I was like,
this is the craziest shit ever week
we've decided that it's normal to lay
this hard surface down on the ground so
we could roll these fire breathing.
Yeah.
It's so crazy,
isn't it?
But it was before that,
it was just a rote.
It was always a road.
But after that it became this weird
symptom of what we're doing by erecting
these massive structures in cities and
that,
you know,
we need this,
this,
this ground in order for us to use these
vehicles on.
And.
But in the process of doing that,
we've sort of marred the landscape with
it everywhere.
Yeah.
Well,
psychedelics do give us the chance to
rethink a lot of things.
You know,
I think we've talked before about um,
uh,
Simon powells work he wrote about,
he writes about Psilocybin,
wrote,
um,
the psilocybin solution and that was his
first book and I think his latest is the
magic mushroom explorer.
But something in his work really struck
me,
which is he pointed out that you have to
look that psychedelics in some sense are
there scientific instruments,
they give you an opportunity to look at
phenomena in a way that you've never
looked at them before because they have
this because they take you out of your
reference frame,
you know,
or they bring the background forward or
there's different ways to describe it.
In Poland actually describes it well
when he talks about this disruption of
the default mode network,
it enables you to see patterns in nature
that you're programmed not to see.
You know,
a lot of what our brain does,
this whole reducing valve idea is it
filters many things out.
It lets in just enough of the external
world that you can relate it to prior
experiences.
What you think you know and you
construct this artificial model of
reality and that's the.
That's what you inhabit.
And I've said this many times may be
worse than pollen,
may be better,
but I talk about how you know,
we're living in a hallucination
essentially that's constructed by our
parades.
And in order to just deal with all the
information that is available,
it has to really restricted at,
has to put a choke on it so that what
does get in can make sense.
That's fine for ordinary consciousness,
but you are prone to overlook things
about reality that are important and
psychedelics temporarily give you an
opportunity to lower those,
lower those mechanisms,
that default network or sometimes called
neural gating.
If you're in a safe place where you
don't have to worry about your safety,
you know,
there is no saber tooth tiger,
we're gonna come get you.
You know,
and so you don't have to worry about
your safety.
Then you can just relax into it and you
can appreciate things that are always
there.
It's not that they're not there,
these are not things you imagine.
They're just things that you never
noticed because you're programmed not
to.
So tremendous learning tools.
And many,
many scientists have said,
you know,
their insights have come from their
psychedelic experience from Steve Jobs
to crick to kary mullis.
Uh,
some of these folks admitted of others,
deny it.
But it's true,
you know.
So there are many,
many things we can learn from
psychedelics that's only one of them,
but from a scientist's perspective,
that's an important one.
You know,
one of the things I want to do is create
a system,
a situation where you can bring
specialists together in different disc
or in,
in a discipline,
say mathematics or quantum physics or
astronomy or even whatever art and have
these collective,
uh,
sessions together and then let people
share their insight,
essentially creative solving,
problem solving or creative sessions.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
and that's,
that's the other thing I think we're
looking for,
you know,
we need to develop a context in which
these things can happen.
Um,
and that's one of the,
you know,
and that's one of the restrictions of,
of the strictly clinical approach that I
chafe against,
you know,
uh,
because they have to be,
you know,
you have to have a problem.
It has to be to treat something
depression or ptsd or whatever.
But we really need to use,
you know,
that's not the only thing.
Psychedelics are good for sure.
They can help people with mental
problems and in our society who doesn't
have mental problems,
you know,
as a society,
we're wounded,
but it goes beyond that.
They are learning tools and teaching
tools and uh,
you know,
you,
you begin to see some of this in the,
uh,
in the work that Roland Griffith is
doing,
you know,
he's been able to get approval for
people to take psilocybin for spiritual
development,
which is not exactly an illness for
actual spiritual insights.
So that's approved to do this.
He is approved to do it and who approved
this and how's it.
The FDA approved it.
He's,
he's got a clinical study going on right
now where he's recruiting a religious
professionals,
people who are pastors,
priests,
rabbis,
the moms,
other types of religious professionals
and putting them through his protocol
and that's having a tremendous impact on
the way they view their profession on
the way they be religion.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
It's,
it really is a shame that we need an
illness to treat for you.
Allow someone to have this potentially
mind expanding experience,
but it's almost like not allowing people
to take vitamins unless they're really
sick.
Yeah,
exactly.
And like Bob Jesse says very eloquently,
we need to find context in which we can
use psychedelics for the betterment of
the.
Well,
you know,
for the improvement of them.
Well,
yeah,
and you can't do it right now under the
current regulatory restrictions now.
I think it's improved.
I think it gradually will improve.
Um,
but this sort of ties into a,
you know,
what I'm trying to do now,
now that I've got this book off my
plate.
I mean this is kind of a kind of a
bucket list item.
Something that I've wanted to do for a
long time and now it's done.
Now I have to help help sell it,
but that won't be too much of a problem.
I think it's a beautiful book,
especially after a year or two after our
show,
it'll probably,
we only published a thousand copies of
those gone.
It would be sold out.
It's a,
a collector's edition and that was on
purpose.
We can always print more,
but it really is beautifully done,
you know,
it is,
it is a beautiful book on every level
and,
and the people that contributed to this,
to the second volume,
I didn't want all the same people that
come to all always come to these
conferences and only say the same
things.
So some of the people in there are not
that well known,
you know,
but they're known.
They were known to me and I felt that
they had important things to say.
So,
uh,
you know,
some of them are known within the
community and,
and others are pretty obscure,
but they,
you know,
there's always this,
this is like,
you know,
this passionate amateur type person who
maybe they don't have credentials,
but they have incredible knowledge up in
their head and they're,
they're completely obsessed with this
stuff.
And there was a few of those people in
there too.
So it's really,
really a really.
It was really satisfying to be able to
do it and make it worth people's
People's time.
When I was able to pay for,
well me and my supporters,
a lot of it came through the Institute
of Ecotechnics actually,
that turned out to be a good nonprofit
channel through which we could get
donations,
grants essentially.
Uh,
we didn't want it to go through heffter
because it might look like a conflict of
interest,
silly notion,
but,
you know,
because of that,
uh,
we were able to pull this off.
We produced the book.
We even gave everybody a modest
honorarium.
So that's the way conferences are
supposed to be.
But um,
what's happening for me now and actually
predates this and has been for a long
time is,
you know,
I've been doing a lot of work in Peru
for really,
I've been hosting retreats for Iowasca
since about 2012.
And,
uh,
that's been very gratifying work.
I've seen transformations in people.
I see what a difference it makes to
create the right environment and get
people able to come and in a safe place.
And my whole approach and the people I
work with,
there are whole approaches.
We're not here to tell you what's
supposed to happen.
We're here to create an optimum
condition and you work it out.
This is a,
this is a dialogue between you and the
plant teacher.
You know,
it's not the Shaman,
the Shaman,
if it's a good,
he was a good showman,
facilitates that process,
but does not try to control it.
He's there for support.
He or she is there for support.
What really happens is the interaction
between,
I mean the,
the,
the medicines or the real teachers.
And we're here to facilitate that.
And also to tell people if they need
help integrating it or figuring it out,
that's fine.
But that's different than saying,
well,
this means that.
And you're supposed to think about it.
You're supposed to think about whatever
you want,
you know,
I mean,
you're supposed to learn to use your own
mind to think for yourself.
So the extension of this is that I'm in
the process,
uh,
of,
I guess manifesting this idea and uh,
what I'm,
what I'm working on now is I want to
create an academy in the Sacred Valley,
which,
uh,
is an academy of natural philosophy and
law.
And so I have a name for it because a
lot of people have told me that,
uh,
you know,
your name has got to be in,
in this,
and I'm a kind of a selfie facing guy,
but,
um,
I recognize that I have a certain iconic
recognition,
so.
Okay,
if that's what it takes,
I'll do it.
So what we're going to call it is the
Mckenna Academy for Natural Philosophy.
And um,
by academy you're saying you don't have
a physical structure.
We will have a physical structure.
Yeah.
And maybe more than one,
but we have identified an initial place
that will be the physical location for
it.
And it's,
it's a kind of school.
It's kind of,
it is in fact the first psychedelic
university,
if you will,
sense this was sacked and burned by the
goths in three 96 a day.
It's the first psychedelic university in
the western tradition since then.
So you're going to have structured
courses,
you're going to have degrees,
all of that.
We're going to have courses.
We're going to have.
It's going to be much more than a
retreat center.
We're going to have retreats.
We're going to have therapeutic programs
for people to get treatment and programs
for people to,
you know,
learn to use psychedelics for therapists
to learn to use them,
but that is not the whole program.
The idea that we're going to have
conferences,
global impact conferences along the
model of this,
this,
this conference was what made me realize
this possible.
We're going to have impactful
conferences that will really have a
global reach and through,
um,
you know,
webinars,
what through the web we can share this
with thousands of people and it will be
a place for it.
It will be a place for,
you know,
the second part of the,
of the title is,
so it's the mechanic academy of natural
philosophy.
What's natural philosophy?
Natural philosophy is what science used
to be called before it became corrupted,
before it became preoccupied with
quantitation before it became
reductionist.
All of the things that have constricted
the scope of science.
This is going to be a more open thing
that doesn't depend on corporate funding
and that sort of thing where first of
all,
we recognize that scientific knowledge
is valuable and we embrace that.
But we also recognize that they has
inherent limitations,
just by the nature of the beast,
it has hinton inherent limitations on
certain things are difficult to,
you know,
to investigate within that rigid
framework.
And,
but they are,
that doesn't mean they're not worthy of
investigation,
you know,
you mean psychedelic experiences.
Very difficult to investigate as many
other things,
paranormal,
you know,
um,
all of these things that people,
you know,
stigmatized as,
as Wu and crazy,
you know,
and I,
we're not going to.
The idea is to bring rigor to these
things to say yes,
there are a lot of phenomena that we
don't understand.
It wasn't a normal phenomenon fascinates
you,
will you name it?
I mean,
Ufo shows is a good example.
Um,
you know,
nobody really knows what's going on with
you for all we know is that people have
these experiences and what are they,
what are those experiences?
Are they extraterrestrial encounters?
We don't know.
A lot of them don't really fit that
mold.
Are they hallucinations or altered
states or is there really something,
you know,
in the continuum that we,
uh,
you know,
that only manifests under certain
circumstances and,
and the idea is that,
you know,
science,
uh,
especially in this era tends to
transform itself into Dogma and then
that becomes dismissive of aspects of
the world that are worthy of studying,
but they don't fit into the scientific
pattern.
And so we dismissed them.
I mean,
a good example of this is Graham
Hancock's work,
for example,
that he talks about and many other
people,
mainstream archeology is not open to
this idea that becoming more open to it
by force data too because more and more
evidence is showing.
But look,
look at how long it's taken him to a,
you know,
knocking on the doors bed and these
people over the head practically that
look at this evidence.
It's very nice though to see him finally
get it.
It is pretty far from over,
but he's definitely gaining ground.
Definitely gaining go for Allie Tabay.
Yeah.
And can you imagine how that would
change our view of humanity or
evolution,
this whole thing?
So archeology is a good,
a good example.
Psychedelics are another good example.
It's opening up,
but for years after the initial
excitement about psychedelics and the
fifties and sixties,
the whole thing was suppressed for 40
years.
Michael Pollan talks about this.
What we're doing now is rediscovering,
you were a psychiatrist in training in
the eighties or the seventies or the
eighties.
You wanted to talk about psychedelics.
That was the end of your career.
You could not even bring this up,
you know,
and,
and who knows.
So it's one of these situations where
it's kind of stunning when you think
about the fact that in the sixties it
probably was possible.
It was before it was made completely
illegal to discuss and I'm on this
conference was performed by the
government,
1967.
Right.
And then the laws changed and laws about
these sorts of things should never be
made by politicians because they always
have,
you know,
a different agenda and they're not
qualified to make these kinds of laws
and they're largely,
you know,
idiots or the ones that really control
power.
They're not informed about psychedelics.
Psychedelics were blankets prohibited
all at once,
pretty much,
and it was,
the focus was all on Lsd.
All these other things got swept up into
this hysteria.
Essentially this hysteria that
psychedelics were gonna change the youth
and Change Society.
And you know what,
they were right?
They were absolutely right.
They were not stupid in that sense.
Uh,
you know,
it did bring out these changes,
but now we're past that.
So
sciences again,
slowly opening up,
you know,
to,
uh,
to psychedelics.
And I think that's a good thing.
Um,
I think people were appreciative of it.
Now that we know that we have gone
through that dip where it was outlawed
and stigmatized and people were never
talking about it.
Like,
you know,
just a few years ago,
I mean,
I want to say early two thousands.
You talk about mushrooms or any sort of
psychedelics and people would look at
you like you're crazy.
Well,
Joe,
I mean,
to his credit,
he was one who continued to talk about
it all through the seventies,
the eighties and nineties.
I mean,
and I give him tremendous credit for
that because he was dismissed and he was
out there.
He was a pioneer and I think he really
had a lot to do with keeping this
conversation alive.
That along with the fact that,
you know,
uh,
largely through our efforts back in the
seventies,
but other people contributed like
statements of other people,
but we published this little pamphlet,
the psilocybin mushroom magic grower's
guide which put in the hands of,
you know,
every nerdy 10th grader essentially the
tools to grow psilocybin mushrooms.
And that's how it got out to the world
and our motivation.
When we did that,
it was partly mercenaries.
Yeah,
we can grow mushrooms,
make a lot of money.
Why don't we,
we grew mushrooms,
we made some money.
But the real motivation is we wanted
people to be able to verify our own
experiences.
The stuff that we experienced at La
Chorrera was so nuts that we thought
either we're completely diluted or
there's something going on here.
So we needed affirmation from a wider
community that,
hey,
there is really weird shit going on
here.
And we put it out and it's now,
you know,
mushrooms are probably a for,
I'd say for most people,
they're the first psychedelic that they
encounter,
you know,
maybe lsd.
But chances are these days it's
mushrooms.
Well,
your brother was such a compelling
speaker.
I mean tests.
Terrence was so interesting.
Like his,
his speech pattern was fascinating.
I mean,
it was part of the thing.
It was the theater of his,
his speeches and lectures there were so
interesting,
you know.
And he also was,
he,
he was so obviously engrossed in these
subjects to the point where he's very,
very attached to them.
It was,
there was a deep connection and he,
you know,
when you would hear him talk and be
like,
shit,
I gotta get some of this stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
he was a compelling speaker.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't rise to that level.
Sorry.
I've just not.
Although occasionally,
you know,
I can kind of channel him,
but um,
but I have stuff to say.
I don't say it as well as he does,
but we,
we were so much on the same wavelength
about this.
So I,
I,
he was the bard of psychedelics
throughout the seventies,
eighties and nineties,
and refused to,
you know,
when no one else was talking about it,
he was talking about it.
So I gave him a lot of credit for.
He kept the emperor.
Yeah.
To do that.
When you were talking about La Chorrera,
uh,
your experiences,
didn't you guys have some sort of a ufo
experience when you were there?
Yes,
we did.
Or he did.
He did.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Interestingly,
um,
I recently,
you know,
I've talked about Lacera probably far
too much and I don't really like to talk
about it too much because it's so hard
to explain and with,
uh,
you know,
and to,
to discuss it,
you get off into these for,
for the uninitiated that we're talking
about in project into these rabbit holes
of,
of explaining.
But I gave a,
a.
I'm a lecturer to breaking convention
last year in the UK and in at the end of
June they have breaking convention.
Another big psychedelic conference.
And I,
my title of my talk was the experiment
at Lusher era,
psychotic break,
shamonic initiation or alien encounter
question mark.
We're all of the above or all of the
above.
Well,
that's
the thing,
but my sort of the theme of this talk
was if you look at the,
uh,
what you might call it,
the,
the topology,
the typology of alien encounters.
There are certain patterns that come up
again and again.
And if you tick those off,
if you say,
you know,
for the experiment lecturer era,
they're all present in a certain way and
there has to be,
you know,
the typical alien encounter.
It's kind of an oxymoron.
What's typical about an alien encounter.
But there are certain characteristics
and one of the characteristics is there
has to be a calling and there has to be
a siren call.
Write something compels you like in a,
in a Spielberg movie,
close encounters of the third kind that
was,
you know,
the,
the table mountain,
you know,
and somehow this guy was compelled to go
there.
Well,
there was a siren call in,
in our experience.
It was DMT,
you know,
and we were just students,
terence was at Berkeley,
I was in University of Colorado,
but we were both fascinated by dmt and
we were compelled to go look for this
orally active form of DMT.
Woo Hoo.
Hey.
Which when we finally got it,
turned out to be not very exciting,
but we,
it took us to La Chorrera.
That's why we went to Lucha Libre was in
quest of this thing,
which we called the secret when we got
to La Chorrera what was really.
There were mushrooms everywhere in the
pasture that quickly reorganized our
priorities.
Right?
And,
and it was though we were in the
presence of this intelligence and it
presented itself very much.
We called it the teacher and it was
downloading all of this information to
us.
And that was another characteristic of,
of alien encounters.
Generic alien encounters usually involve
the transfer of special information.
People are shown a book or they're
shown,
you know,
uh,
something that is transmitted from the
teacher to the recipient.
And we,
we got that in spades.
We got this encounter and it had those
characteristics.
And then another characteristic is
there,
there is,
so information is given and gifts are
given,
you know,
and the information that was transmitted
resulted in a couple of things.
Well,
the primary thing that that came out of
that was terrence's idea about the time
about timewave and teaching.
The genesis of that idea came out of the
experiment that lecturer and then over
decades became refined and developed.
Now,
whether there's any to it,
I'm not sure.
I've always been very skeptical about it
and you know,
it,
it failed its major test,
which is the space time continuum did
not collapse on December 20,
first 2012 as was predicted.
But there are interesting things about
the,
about the timeline,
if it's just an interesting thing
considered,
um,
you know,
in its own context as a strange
mathematic whole construction that in
many ways as a reflection of terrence's
psyche,
he was the only one that could really
understand it and interpret it.
This is a bunch of people listening
probably don't know what we're talking
about.
We're talking about timewave zero,
timewave zero,
right?
And we wrote the invisible landscape in
our first book for people who have no
idea what we're talking about.
Explain what timewave zero.
Okay.
Rhythm essentially that he essentially
it was an algorithm based on the
structure of the each thing.
This oracle of 64 hexagrams,
and he treated it in such a way that he
claimed it,
it describes that time had a structure
and that this thing was that this,
this timewave describe the structure of
time essentially,
and thus was a predictive tool among
other things.
And that it,
uh,
you know,
was a way to look at the ingression of
novelty into the continuum.
The idea that there really are new
things under the sun,
new things happen that have never
happened before ever in the history of
the universe.
And this map was a way to predict the
eruption of those things or the
ingression of those things,
I think,
which is a better term.
And terrence and I used to have,
you know,
I wouldn't call them arguments,
I'd call them heated discussions,
uh,
or enthusiastic discussions about how
this happened.
I do not disagree with the principle
that there is novelty.
I'm not sure the timewave really
describes it adequately,
but it was a,
it was a attempt to,
and uh,
and whatever it was,
it was something that was a gift from
this teacher,
at least the,
the nugget of the idea that.
Right.
The other thing that came back,
the other gift that came back from La
Chorrera was nothing supernatural or
anything like that.
The gift was the spores of the mushroom.
We took the spores of the mushroom and
we took them back with us and then over
two or three years we figured out how to
grow them and we shared that with the
rest of the world.
And that was really the thing that,
and look at the impact that that's had
on society.
You know,
and terrence was fond of saying,
terrence did say,
you know,
we are in a symbiotic relationship with
something that has disguised itself as
an alien invasion in order not to alarm
us.
Right.
So,
and that's what it was.
And,
and before you know it,
every nerdy 10th year,
a 10 year old in basements across the
country,
you know,
we're growing mushrooms and able to do
it because the [inaudible] the technique
was very simple.
So it's all about what's Johnny doing
down in the basement,
honey,
oh,
I don't know,
some science project,
something about growing mushrooms.
So effectively the alien invasion was a
complete success,
not a shot was fired,
you know,
and now here we are and no one's even
realized that it's an alien invasion.
Do you subscribe to the idea that
mushrooms came here and perhaps on
asteroids that it was a Panspermia sort
of situation?
Oh,
I don't know.
I don't subscribe to that idea.
Whose idea was that?
Well,
terrence's idea,
you know,
um,
and the idea of Panspermia I don't
necessarily disagree with that.
I think that may well have happened.
Um,
you know,
that that life came from on an asteroid
or is the building blocks the building
blocks of it.
But mushrooms as such,
we know too much about the phylogeny of
mushrooms.
We know where they fit into the
phylogeny of life on earth.
And it can't really make the case that
they were extraterrestrial because there
were mushrooms,
you know,
their mushrooms and they're part of,
they have a position in the well defined
phylogeny of fungi,
which are some of the most ancient
organisms,
I mean,
some of the most earliest macro or a
terrestrial organisms that were of a
macro scale.
We're fungi.
I mean,
there were big fungi on,
on interest rate environments before
there was much of anything else,
but they weren't siliciden mushrooms
presumably have you paid attention to
this most recent theory that perhaps,
uh,
the ancestors of octopus might have
somehow or another gotten here from an
asteroid that there,
there's something about their unique
ability to alter their rna which is
unique in the animal kingdom.
I have heard about that.
Um,
and I have a legit sources apparently.
Right.
It's not a real legit sources,
honestly.
I haven't read far enough into that to
just decide.
Um,
but if anything,
it seems like an alien.
Yeah.
Well,
they certainly look.
They look like our idea of an alien.
Yeah.
Really.
We probably looked like aliens to
octopus,
so.
Sure.
But,
you know,
another,
um,
another interesting,
maybe interesting angle on this was I,
um,
uh,
yeah,
I think it was 2015.
I was invited to another private
conference actually at tiering ham and
the subject of the conference was dmt
entities and uh,
you know,
are the entities you see on Dmt,
are they real or not tall order?
Very difficult to really unpack that for
one thing.
What do you mean by real?
Let's start there.
Anything you experienced is real,
right?
You know,
so start there.
Um,
but the talk that I presented was called
a is dmt a messenger molecule from an
extraterrestrial civilization.
That was the title of my talk.
And I actually,
in the course of preparing the talk,
I had to conclude that probably not,
you know,
because if you're going to postulate
that what you really have to talk about
is uh,
the origin of tryptofan because
tryptofan the amino acid which is found
in everything.
It's one of the 20 that goes into
protein.
Tryptofan is the precursor to all these
psychedelic tryptamines and,
and also including Serotonin.
You know,
dmt is kind of the archetypal
Psychedelic,
but you've got silicide been siliciden
five methoxy before [inaudible] and even
the Beta carbon lanes.
So,
so if you look back in Phylogeny,
um,
you know,
a billion years,
a couple of billion years,
eventually you're talking about what
they call the trip opera,
which is the cluster of genes that give
rise to tryptofan.
So we pretty certain you're not talking
about is dmt extraterrestrial in origin.
You have to say,
well,
obviously it's,
it,
it came from tryptofan.
So how'd the trip on a arise in
phylogeny it was that extra terrestrial,
even though it's one of the most
ancient,
uh,
gene clusters in,
in the evolution of life,
you can't really make the case that it's
extraterrestrial because you could say,
well,
it came from,
um,
Rhodopsin actually the genes that the
trip opera opera on originated from
originally where the genes that the same
genes that code for Rhodopsin,
which is the pigment in the eye that
responds to light.
So I ended up,
I could make the case that dmt is extra
terrestrial and,
but is that a,
it's been an interesting case.
Like whether or not it's from another
planet,
whatever it is,
it's,
it doesn't seem like it's here.
The experience does it.
It doesn't seem like it's here.
Right.
But,
but then again,
where is here,
you know,
eventually I defaulted to say it may not
be an extra terrestrial messenger
molecule,
but it is a messenger molecule and it is
a distinctly terrestrial messenger
molecule.
It is the messenger molecule that has
been adopted by the community of species
to talk to the monkeys and try to,
you know,
talk to our consciousness and maybe even
to trigger consciousness.
So dmt is only two steps from tryptofan
and somatically and cellular metabolism.
Tryptofan is universal,
not a living thing that we know of that
does not contain trip to fan because
it's one of the 20 that go into amino
acids to steps from Tryptofan,
decarboxylation and,
and methylation is all it takes to get
dmt.
And that's like the prototypal
tryptamine psychedelic and the enzymes
that catalyze those steps.
They may not be universal in organisms,
but they're pretty darn near universal
because they have all sorts of other
cellular housekeeping functions.
You know,
decarboxylated amino acids as something
that goes on in every cell,
sticking methyl groups on nitrogens is
maybe less,
less common,
but still very common,
you know,
enzymes that will move a methyl groups
around in sales so you can make the case
that,
and we know this,
dmt is extremely common in nature.
DMT is.
I said nature is drenched in Dmt,
you know,
from the animal level to the plant
level,
to the fungal level.
You find these things everywhere.
Um,
you know,
um,
and people say,
well,
there's about a hundred and 50 species
of plants that contain dmt.
That's only because we've only looked at
150 species of plants.
You know,
if you look at these large genera that
are,
that are,
you know,
famous known for having tryptamines like
Acacias and my Moses and these things.
Uh,
we know of a few species that have dmt,
but there's hundreds of species,
thousands of species.
It's just that nobody's looked.
Nobody's going to fund this work.
I think you can reasonably say that you
know,
there are about 1400 species of Acacia
in the world.
Probably 75 percent of them have dmt and
actually I would go to the next.
I would.
I would even claim without evidence.
That's never stopped me before,
but I think it's reasonable to suppose
that because dmt is so close to
mainstream metabolism,
probably all plants have dmt to some
extent.
Most don't have large,
large levels of it.
They don't have useful amounts of DMT,
but if you
took with sufficient instruments,
if you just started ranting randomly
sampling plan,
some analyzing for dmt with the Mass
Spec,
I'll bet it would turn up in almost
everything.
What is.
Which is hilarious.
Grass that's toxic to sheep because of
DMT.
Yup.
That's the one.
So the DMT in it for whatever reason,
way it interacts with the sheeps
digestive system becomes poisoned the.
Well,
no,
not entirely.
I mean it's got flares.
Grass has dmt.
It has five methoxy DMT,
other tryptamines.
It also has something called grameen,
which has a.
it's like dmt with only one carbon on
the side chain.
Grameen is more or less toxic.
Graming shows up in a lot of grass
species.
That's probably the thing that causes
what's called Polaris staggers.
So if you just fed dmt a synthesized to
sheep,
it wouldn't be toxic.
Hard to say.
Did they produce monoamine oxidase?
Nobody's done it to shape.
Yeah,
of course.
So do leopards or jaguars all mammals.
So when you see those jaguars eating the
leaves and then tripping their balls
off,
rolling around on their back,
what do you think is happening there?
You've seen those videos.
I've seen those videos.
Well,
for one thing,
they were eating a banisteriopsis right?
Which is the source of the Mao
inhibitors.
Right?
And I don't know what to make of that.
It certainly does seem like some kind of
a catnip for them,
you know,
and causes an altered state for Mao
inhibitors in,
in an of themselves.
They produce some sort of a psychedelic
experience.
Uh,
they can,
um,
not just from the Mao inhibition,
but they often have other effects that
are psychoactive,
like harm.
Harming Armenia is a good example.
You know,
we used to think that harming was
basically,
it's the Mao inhibitor and Iowasca that
doesn't do a whole lot beyond that.
Well,
it turns out now harming this,
getting a second look.
It's interesting that the tar mean,
uh,
you know,
was discovered in [inaudible] about
maybe 10 years before Iowasca was ever
reported to science.
So harming is one of these hoary old
alkaloids,
I like to call it,
you know,
it's been known forever and now we're
just finding out it has all sorts of
interesting pharmacology.
It's an Mao inhibitor for sure.
More importantly,
it appears that it stimulates
neurogenesis and that's relevant to
Alzheimer's and brain development.
And even down syndrome.
It is an inhibitor of this kinase,
this regulatory protein called Dyr k
one,
which has got its fingers in lots of
different cellular pies.
You could pull it many different
regulatory functions.
And harming is a very potent,
very selective inhibitor of this kinase.
So that's relates to this.
It actually stimulates nerve growth in
the hippocampus.
So,
uh,
you know,
we're at and we're finding out that
there are a number of other receptors
that it interacts with,
including Serotonin,
dopamine,
transporters,
even one called the imaginal iin
receptors that are,
uh,
you know,
have undefined functions.
So like most natural molecules,
it's not a one trick pony,
you know,
harming has a number of effects,
and that's why taking Iowasca is a
different,
you know,
it.
That's why it's not a pure dmt
experience because you've got a whole
mixture of alkaloids that are,
that are contributing to that effect.
Who were the researchers that when they
discovered harming,
they didn't know what it was and they
tried to label it telepathy to.
They realized that it was harming,
right?
Right.
Well,
yeah,
this is part of the,
uh,
what you may call the,
the,
the sad and sorted history of the,
of Iowasca in a certain way because in
the early days,
in the twenties when people are looking
at it,
I'm a number of independent groups.
We're working on it.
And they were identified,
they were isolated molecules.
They weren't aware of other people's
work.
And so they misnamed these things,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
I can't tell you exactly.
I think initially it was Lewis Lewis who
discovered a harming and he called it
business history.
And then it turned out,
well,
another group years before had isolated
the same molecule from Ghanim hormonally
and telepathy was one of these
misnomers,
you know,
that,
that came out.
The problem with,
with this was that back in the day
people didn't collect voucher specimens.
So a lot of this chemical work was done
without the benefit of or barium
specimens,
which now every everybody that wants to
do fido chemical work hopefully has the
good sense to collect specimens of the
original plant so that people can go
back and look at that.
A lot of this early work was reported
and there was no voucher specimens to
document the collection.
So a lot of it had to be dismissed,
you know,
uh,
they can the Beta carbon chemistry of
abs,
three opsis didn't really get
well-defined until,
um,
some Chinese scientists,
uh,
or at least they had Chinese name worked
on them
and discovered harming,
tetra hydro harming and the [inaudible]
as the main alkaloids.
They could reference that to botanical
voucher specimens.
So they really should get the credit for
discovering it.
And then once that was done,
then it was known and you know,
other scientists had to acknowledge
that,
why did they describe it as telepathy
and that there was supposedly some sort
of a story about some group telepathic
experience.
This was just romantic.
This was just some story,
you know,
out of the literature.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I mean it,
it was rumored to be able to cause
telepathy,
but this wasn't Iowasca.
They were only taking hormones.
It's not clear.
Yeah.
I mean,
they may have been taken,
but they may have been taking it,
but whether they were getting telepathy,
I kind of doubt it when we know we could
get telepathy on Iowasca.
It's not so uncommon.
It happens all the time.
People have group hallucinations,
group visions.
Has anybody ever bothered to
independently,
like sequester people,
put them into different rooms,
have them do Iowaska and then have them
describe a very similar experience are
almost identical experience to prove
that these telepath he experiences exist
or at least to.
As far as I know,
that hasn't been the same.
Yeah,
because everybody wants to talk
afterwards.
I just see the dragon.
I don't think that's been done.
That seems like a worthy study because
if.
If I've heard from more than one person.
In fact my friend Kyle Kingsbury and his
wife had an ios experience with a both a
had a visualization of their child and
then when they got back she was pregnant
and they wound up having this child from
their visualization from,
from,
from this experience.
Obviously they're very close and they
were together and they probably
communicated quite a bit and I would
just think it would be a really
interesting experiment.
It would be very interesting.
I mean,
and that sort of points out there is a
realm of experience,
a realm of knowing that these things
give access to that's normally close to
us.
I mean,
it's kind of a trivial statement of
course.
Um,
but then you get down to questions of
how verifiable is that,
how real is that?
How,
uh,
you know,
and,
and people get a,
I don't know if the term is hung up,
but they can get baffled when you start
talking about,
you know,
the reality of say the entities you
encounter on dmt.
I mean this is,
this is some people I know are obsessed
with trying to verify the reality of the
entities that find on dmt.
And again,
it comes down to if you experienced
them,
they're real.
If anything you experienced is real
because you've experienced it,
does it have a corresponding existence
in the external world?
Well,
you know,
what's external?
What's eating turtle?
You know,
we,
we throw around these terms,
these,
these epistomological metaphysical terms
quite carelessly,
you know,
without really thinking about it.
What does it mean when you say,
I'm in here and you're out there.
You know,
and then you take a psychedelic and you
realize that's an artificial boundary.
You know,
we're all one.
There is no separation.
It's separate in normal consciousness
though it's separated in normal
conscious,
but then what is normal conscious if not
a reflection of year,
neurochemical brain,
state.
I mean everything you experience is an
altered state because it's filtered into
this brain,
processed by the brain and you know the
brain is a biochemical engine that you
know,
as I say,
often were made out of drug,
so it seems that our normal
consciousness is the best state to
propagate biological life and to keep
our,
our whatever we've created in terms of
our community structures and
relationships and friendships and the
ability to build structures and houses
and things like that.
These,
all of these things are done best when
you're here and present.
Whereas when you're on a psychedelic
state,
I agree with you.
Well,
the way I've always described it as if
you had a meeting with God and you went
and God gave you all the answers to the
world and you,
you experienced a undeniable beauty in
the most extreme form possible where you
couldn't have imagined it and then you
came back whether you hallucinated it or
not,
it's the exact same experience.
Exactly.
I can't put it on a scale right away.
It was like we've stretched the tape
measure around and God is 47 inches
across.
Like just because,
you know what I'm saying?
Just because you can't measure it with
what we term our,
our,
you know,
our metrics for reality.
Right?
And that is exactly the thing.
Don't worry about whether it's real and
the way we would define real.
Is it good information or is it bad or
is it not?
That's the thing.
It doesn't matter where it comes from,
it's such a fits good information.
Then it has its own internal validity of
whether it came from some part of
yourself that is normally obscurity you
or,
uh,
came from the plant teacher or the
aliens transmitting it through.
It doesn't really matter,
but we we're obsessed with that reality
because we think we're being fooled a
lot.
Right?
Like in this goes back to terrance's La
Chorrera psychedelic,
where he had a Ufo encounter.
You know,
the,
the easily dismissing amongst us will
go,
well,
he's tripping his balls off on
mushrooms.
Of course I saw you was,
or a leprechaun drive in the UFO.
Like all that's nonsense,
right?
Be Easy to dismiss as in fact,
that is the nature of these phenomena.
That's what's really interesting.
Easy to dismiss that.
That was another aspect of the
experiment of La Truro.
I left out when I was talking about my
lecture,
but there's almost always an element of
absurdity in these experiences and in
paranormal experiences,
in Ufo encounters.
It's like little green men bond,
are you kidding?
But the fuck there are little green man
and little blue man.
You know a guy who should have on the
show.
Maybe you have already a is Whitley
strieber?
No,
I haven't had him on,
but he's so out to lunch.
I have massive reservations.
There's a video of him looking at a fly
in fly.
Clearly a fly flies in front of a camera
and he's describing it.
Is this a man in a suit?
And it's like there's something wrong
with them.
Well,
I missed that.
I missed that part.
I think what's interesting about
Whitley,
and I agree,
I totally dismissed him,
you know,
for a long time.
I thought,
you know,
he is really a nutcase.
He's from the communion books or people
that don't know exactly what a series of
books about being abducted and.
Yeah,
but I sort of had to change my opinion
somewhat because he and uh,
and uh,
Jeffrey cripple,
who I do know is Jeffrey Carpool is a
professor of comparative religion and
mythology at Rice university and his
focus initially as a sort of the,
the superhero,
as,
as in contemporary mythology as a
mythical figure in that sort of thing.
He.
And uh,
I was invited to a,
a simple,
a workshop that Whitley was going to be
at.
This was a couple of years ago in
Hawaii.
While I'm always interested in a free
trip to Hawaii.
Right?
So I said,
I,
you know,
I'd like to come to this thing,
but this guy is a nut case,
I'm not sure I want to appear on the
same stage with this guy and if it's me
saying that,
you know,
and uh,
and the guy who was hosting it said,
well,
you know,
did you know that he and Jeffrey Carpal
wrote a book together?
And I said,
Whoa,
I don't.
I said that.
I know Jeffrey cripple.
I know that he's not on that case.
And that's interesting.
And then I found out about the book and
I said,
I,
I told the guy,
if you invite Geoffrey and Whitley,
then all come and will participate.
The name of the book is a supernatural
two words,
supernatural,
a new vision of the unexplained.
And it's really very interesting.
Um,
the book is basically,
you know,
alternating chapters.
Whitley tells us stories about what
happened to it and what has happened to
and what continues to happen to him.
He lives in some kind of alternate
reality.
I,
t,
I get that.
I mean,
I don't know if I accept it,
but I get it.
And then in alternating chapters,
Jeffrey comes along and kind of unpacks
this and explained where does this fit
into sort of the,
the phenomenology of mythology and,
you know,
reasonable explanations and uh,
and it's a fascinating book.
If you just suspend disbelief for a
minute,
think about,
assume that Whitley's is sincere.
I don't think he's lying.
I think that these things really
happened to him or he thinks they do and
some of the most craziest things,
these are not,
you know,
the media has made like everything,
they dumb it down,
you know,
and they,
they put it into the box of alien
encounters guys,
a nutball,
uh,
you know,
and they dismiss it.
But if you take a closer look,
one thing to Whitley's credit is he
doesn't claim to understand what's
happening.
He doesn't call it an alien encounter.
He doesn't claim anything.
He just says this is happening.
I have no frigging idea what is,
what this is.
So that's honest,
you know,
that's an honest scientific stance.
I do not understand this phenomenon.
So I gave him credit for that and then
he and,
and Jeffrey wrote this book.
There was a very interesting,
uh,
you know,
later on.
So I read all this later on in the book.
There's a chapter where they get to what
is the possible physical explanation of
what's going on here.
If there is a physical explanation and
one of the headings,
I think the chapter one of the headings
and the chapter was labeled the soul as
a Ufo.
And that kind of blew my mind.
That got my attention because,
you know,
when I did this workshop with them,
I was kind of bringing the flag of
Psychedelics,
right?
That was saying,
if you don't aggress psychedelics,
you've only got part of the picture
here.
And uh,
and they,
and they were talking about how the
soul,
how this could be some sort of a
physical plaza moist type of thing.
They were invoking scientific
terminology.
I don't know if it was,
it was legitimate or not,
but just the idea of the soul of a Ufo.
And I was able to respond to that and
say,
well,
you know,
the experiment at launch,
earl was essentially the blueprints of
how to build one of these things that
you're talking to,
which it was really this,
this transformation.
And so that was,
that impressed me.
I don't know what to make of that.
I think.
I think there is and they don't really
know.
Nobody knows what to make of it,
but I think there just odd things going
on.
Um,
but that some people experience yes.
And uh,
and whether they are actual encounters
or dreams or somewhere in between.
I'm not sure.
It would be cool.
It would be good.
I mean,
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
when you,
when you meet Whitley,
have you ever met him?
No,
he is like the most drab person you
could imagine.
I mean he's like an accountant or
something
probably worn out from telling all these
stories.
Could be,
could be.
But he was.
But he was a fiction writer.
He was a fiction writer.
And then he comes out with this
incredible real world story reads like
fiction and I.
There's obviously something off when you
talk to him or you hear him and I've
never talked to him personally,
but when you see him in interviews and
conversations,
there's something off now.
What is that something off?
Is it a psychotic break?
Is it something that drifts in and out?
Does he,
is he having problems with normal
consciousness?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know what it is,
but I thought I'm really,
if you can find that video of him
talking about the fly.
Did you find it flies a man in a fucking
space suit.
He's like,
it's not a man in a suit.
What is that?
And I'm like,
oh Jesus.
To the lunch called the Ben with quite a
few of those.
There's quite a few really bizarre
videos of him when he's having a hard
time with normal reality.
So which would make sense during the
dream state because all of these things
are happening at night.
Right,
right,
right.
This was the,
this is the big thing that I've always.
Big Problem I've always had about these
UFO abduction experiences.
First of all,
they all take place when someone is
either a at night,
it's either they're on a dark road where
there's no one around and they're sleepy
or they're at home and their bed like
the vast majority of them take place at
night or while someone's lying in bed,
which is exactly when you're dreaming.
Now we don't totally understand the
dream state,
but we there's,
there's a connection,
at least an implied connection between
psychedelic chemicals that your brain
produces endogenously that could be
released during the dream state and in
different levels with different humans.
I mean obviously some people have
problems with producing serotonin and
dopamine and then other people have no
problems with it and this biology of the
human brain varies,
right?
So it's not without consider it or not
without possibility that there's someone
who has a real issue with these
chemicals just bust in through right
flooding there.
Are we,
oh wait,
no,
there aren't people then does this
mental illness,
but then does this contradict what we've
already said about psychedelic
experiences?
Like why would we diminish his
indogenous psychedelic experience if
that's what he's having.
I mean,
it is entirely possible that you're
dealing with someone who maybe perhaps
does have some sort of psychotic breaks,
but also is experiencing psychedelic
experiences due to some endogenous DMT
dump or dump of whatever.
And all these things are taking place at
the same time in the dream state during
heavy rem sleep.
And he's coming back with these uniform
stories of alien abduction.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
It's,
it's.
I mean it's hard to
Parse it out.
I'm not saying I accept it all,
but I,
it's easy to dismiss,
but maybe you shouldn't write.
Well there may be something there.
We should approach it in the spirit of
here's a phenomenon.
We don't understand that we shouldn't
dismiss it.
There's something to be understood here.
Not necessarily his understanding of it,
but something to be looked at there.
And I thought this book was interesting
for its balanced.
You know,
I would not have Whitley strieber on
your show without Jeffrey cry a lot.
So that was the thing.
Cause he,
it would be fun
and maybe it's,
you know,
maybe it's a bridge too far.
I'm not.
Yeah,
maybe that maybe we get to the bottom of
this thing.
Yeah.
Well,
is there something to be got to the
bottom right?
That's,
that's the bottom of this is just one
man's delusion or is there really
something that.
The base of it,
and this is the,
this is kind of the point that we were
talking about a while back and this
conversation about natural philosophy,
natural philosophy,
you know,
it has a wider scope for understanding
and you can say,
well,
you meaning natural philosophy will
accept every Kaka may mean woo idea that
ever came along.
Not Properly.
I mean,
it's natural philosophy.
Properly approached,
should be a way to evaluate these things
rigorously,
not abandoned,
rigorous thought,
but not be so dismissive of it as to say
it doesn't fit into our paradigm.
It doesn't fit into what we think we
know.
So we're not going to talk about.
That's dishonest.
That's intellectual dishonesty.
And uh,
we have too much of that.
You know,
sciences are very timid.
I'm kind of activity sometimes because
in its current,
in its current incarnation,
it's so depend,
it's,
it's corrupted in a certain way.
You can't just be the curious monkey
who's trying to apply,
you know,
clear thinking,
rigorous thought to understanding
nature.
We don't have that.
Luxury scientists don't have that
luxury.
If they're practicing scientists,
you have to be getting grants,
you have to play the science game.
So that's what he keeps saying sciences
corrupted.
That's what you mean by that.
They have to get grants.
Not that they have to,
that's part of it.
They,
they have to get grants and they have to
be dishonest.
Right?
I mean with themselves,
with what they know,
like the example of the archeologists or
the psychedelic researchers back in the
80.
If you want to kill your career,
tell your supervisor that you wanted to
work on psychedelics.
You were pretty much done.
Or if you were an archeologist and you
said,
but,
but you know,
look,
there's all this evidence for ancient
civilizations.
It's like you want to be in this
department,
kid,
you're outta here.
If you start talking about that.
So science is dogma in a lot of ways.
Not always,
but it's unfortunate that no,
in order to save people's careers,
in order to have a career in science,
you have to make the sacrifice.
You have to,
you have to keep to yourself things you
know to be true.
You know that you can't really talk
about because your colleagues will look
askance at you and sciences.
A very medieval institution in that
respect.
It's a lot like religion.
You know,
when you look at the DMT experience and
you look at its effect on the human
mind,
how much have you subscribes to.
The idea that we're looking at is some
sort of a chemical gateway,
chemical gateway to what,
whatever it is to whatever that dmt
experiences that this is something that
your brain has the ability to travel to.
But I mean when we,
since we know that the body does produce
this and we know that possible for
people to.
Yeah,
I mean I've never done it,
but I know that people who do Kundalini
Yoga have apparently reported trip,
like experiences that are very similar
to a real dmt flash.
So the mind has this ability to do this
on its own.
What do you think that that,
is that something worth considering that
this is,
this is some sort of a pathway to a
nearby dimension or the to something
that's around us all the time,
but we just don't have access to with
normal neurochemistry
all there are too many what ifs or who
knows?
I mean there's,
you know,
there's so much in what you said where
you have to go
back and unpack all of these things.
When we got excited about dmt terence
than me in the early,
in the late sixties,
what led is to go to La Chorrera was
that it seemed like a completely
different order of magnitude than any of
the other psychedelics.
And we came to it really from a
childhood that was steeped in science
fiction.
So we carried with the,
with us the idea,
this really is another dimension and it
may be a portal to another dimension.
And as science fiction nuts,
we were totally okay with that.
Yeah.
And we thought maybe DMT was.
And maybe it is,
but,
or it's somehow pulls the curtain back
on something that's around us all the
time that we don't see.
Um,
but again,
in thinking about these things,
is it something that is entirely within
the brain that it originates?
Or is it something that,
is it like a lens that you know,
or our eyes are covered with,
with,
uh,
with filters and DMT temporarily removes
those filters?
I think it's hard to know.
I mean,
I think maybe experimentally we could,
we could begin to approach this.
Have you,
you know,
am I,
I think we really know.
I think that's another thing about
natural philosophy,
um,
that's important that science is
overlooking and natural philosophy
always remembers the limits of what is
known,
you know,
and sciences a bit arrogant about what
they think is known.
You know,
they only have,
science only understands a small
fraction of all there is to know.
And Iowasca another psychedelic always
remind me of this when I take it.
Remember the limitations of your
knowledge or sometimes it's more or less
kindly says it.
You don't know shit.
And it's true.
We don't know.
You know,
and scientists can forget that,
you know,
but as far as this dmt a thing,
this is actually a,
there's controversy about this because,
uh,
you know,
um,
a lot of,
a lot of people who have worked in this
area say it's,
it's pretty well established that
endogenous dmt can produce these states,
that the neil can secrete dmt under
certain circumstances or under stress.
The lungs can produce large amounts of
dmt that are translocated to the brain.
Um,
but it's not so clear that that goes on.
I mean,
it's clear that it can be produced.
But David Nichols,
you know,
who knows a thing or two about
pharmacology,
founder of the heffter institute worlds,
you know,
most authoritative,
highest authority when it comes to the
chemistry and pharmacology of,
of psychedelics.
He's,
he's taken the reductionist argument on
this that's kind of hard to,
uh,
to knock down,
which is that DMT is produced
endogenously,
but it's chopped up so quickly that it
never reaches the site of action and it
never reaches the levels at the neuron
that it would take to activate the
neurons.
Um,
you know,
so we only consumed or are you saying
endogenously produced the endogenously
so that it does,
when you consume it,
obviously you flood the system and
you'll get much higher levels than has
ever produced endogenously and I,
but we haven't really measured the
levels produced endogenously during,
especially these extreme states.
And that's part of the problem.
That's part of the problem.
How do you do that?
Have you done,
do you do that?
What?
Have you done Kundalini and tried to
recreate?
No,
I haven't either.
I've met terrence had that fantastic
joke.
Uh,
it was a talk about that this monk had a
practice,
the city of levitation.
Do you remember this one?
And uh,
that uh,
the Buddha came to town and he said for
the last 20 years I've practiced the
city of levitation and I can now walk on
water.
And the Buddhist said,
yeah,
but the ferries only a nickel.
It's like you want to practice Kundalini
for 10 years and Bang your head towards
the east or just smoked dmt and 30
seconds later I run a center of the
universe.
But I think the last time I was on your
show,
we talked about this,
uh,
this other thing,
this agile light we discussed.
Yes.
And I don't know if you've interviewed.
Yeah,
we have to buy you one.
I said we were,
we totally dropped the ball on that.
You don't have to buy.
No,
we do have to buy you want by yourself
while I'm going to buy myself one menu
and this time we're going to do it.
We said we're going to do too many
podcasts.
I forget everything.
I know I,
I've never bought that.
Agilent is interesting because,
you know,
I mean he claims and that was the
conversation we had.
He claimed,
yes,
this stimulates and dodges synthesis of
writing this down.
Right now it's a j.
A n a homage,
no light.
And his website is just [inaudible] dot
com.
And there's some good pdfs on there
that'll explain what this is about.
That Jamie.
Yeah.
And a big time because I just mentioned
this,
but anyway,
so this light can produce some sort of
psych,
no experience.
He claims it stimulates dmt synthesis in
the pineal.
When you lie underneath that assist,
a bunch of it's,
it looks like a floor lamp,
you know,
with a rectangular mount bunch of leds
underneath it,
which he programs with an ipad and
different patterns.
You lie under it and you.
It stimulates hypnagogic hallucinations
that are a lot like that guy looks like
an old school freak looking at him.
He's a zen monk.
I bet he is.
Amongst other things.
He used to be an apple engineer.
He was jobs right hand man when wow.
He went the right way.
So he's got this thing.
Is that cord going down to her head and
hard time seeing what's happening.
Something's wrapped around her head.
That better not be a crystal.
I think that running out of this room.
No,
I think that's deceptive thing.
He didn't attach anything to me.
Perspective Issue Court binder.
So you lie under this thing.
And first time I lived under it I
thought I got all these colors.
I got all these hypnagogic effects,
you know,
and nice patterns and all that.
Like a sub threshold DMT experience.
And I said,
well,
you know,
the,
uh,
the leds are all changing color,
right?
And that's how I see it.
He says,
no,
they're white.
The colors are coming from you.
You're supplying the colors.
So,
okay.
So it was interesting.
And then we got into the conversation.
How do you know this is stimulating dmt?
How do you know that's the effect?
It turns out it's not so easy to nail
that down,
you know,
because the empty is sore femoral and
the system,
you can't take urine samples or cerebral
spinal fluid or anything.
It would be gone by the time you did it.
So the only way,
well maybe not the only way,
but one way you could do it is you could
do something called a,
um,
it's essentially you couldn't do this to
a human [inaudible].
You couldn't,
you couldn't get an FDA approval for it,
but you could put a micro capillary tube
right next to the pineal that will
absorb things as they are released.
And then you could recover that and say,
you know,
levels of DMT or why couldn't you do
that to a voluntary participant?
Voluntary or not?
You'd be screwing their brain up.
Well,
no,
not necessarily,
but you'd have a hard time getting
permission.
There might be.
You could do it to a rat though.
You could do it too.
That's what cottonwood research
foundation's done,
right?
They've done that.
That's how they discovered dmt and the
pineal,
um,
to a live rat.
Yeah.
That's how they discovered it.
That was the first proof,
right?
That was the first proof.
Nick Cozy,
um,
who's a pharmacologists at the
University of Wisconsin at Madison.
He was really the first one to show that
DMT is endogenously produced.
It's sigma one agonist as well as a
Serotonin agonist,
which is another,
another receptor.
No,
the definitely that,
but it's not clear what the function is.
It's,
it's a complicated issue,
you know,
um,
to figure this out,
I'll send you a paper that Nicole's
rotor elite.
I'll link you to a video where he
discusses this and it's like,
you know,
he gave that at the breaking convention
conference last summer that I was at and
it was like,
you know,
he was like the big Downer of the
conference,
right?
Because everybody has this romantic idea
and he comes along and just squashes it,
you know,
and it's like,
man,
you know,
have disappointed a lot of people.
But on the other hand,
reality is good.
Facts are good.
What a guy did do that,
uh,
the sort of made me think,
made me think maybe there is something
to it.
He's tried,
um,
pre dosing with an Mao inhibitor.
Just take a stereopsis t without the
admixture about 30 minutes before going
under the light and then the,
it's much more intense of it's much more
prolonged.
You've done this.
I haven't done it,
but he claims that have other people say
that it definitely enhances the.
So that would indicate that the
breakdown of DMT is being
inhibited.
Is he claiming that you could reach
actual dmt states with this device upon
practice?
Yeah.
What about in the tank?
Well,
seems designed for the tank,
but how do you,
how do you put the light in the tank?
You just suspended,
suspended from the ceiling and put a
switch on the wall,
climb in,
hit the switch and lay down.
You could try it.
I'm going to try it.
That seems like the way I'm going to get
a hold of crash from the float lab
because crash was trying to put a.
he's the mad scientist behind the float
lab,
which is the most advanced serum he saw,
that contraption that we have back there
that is state of the art as it gets in
the world of tanks and he had a concept
for developing learning,
uh,
films,
films where you would lie down and in
the absence of any physical input,
right,
or very minimal be meaning that you're
floating in that environment.
He was going to suspend an LCD screen at
the lowest possible light emission.
So you would not be able to see the
edges of the screen.
You would just be able to see the images
on the screen and they would play
instructional videos and things and you
would learn them with the minimal amount
of distractions and you think you could
achieve.
His thought was that you could achieve
accelerated learning.
Like,
yeah,
like perhaps you could work on your golf
swing or something like that or some
thing that you could get in there or
maybe musical instruments that you'd be
able to pick up concepts and things with
minimal distraction.
Oh,
that's very interesting.
You have a lot of experience with the
tank.
Almost none.
Oh,
it's so great.
You,
you would love it.
And it's really great for working out
ideas for one of the best environments
in the world for working on a,
a thought because there's no input.
You're not thinking about anything else.
You just in total silence,
total darkness,
very relaxing.
You're floating and you,
you know,
in the absence of this input,
you,
your brain has more resources.
Is it similar to a psychedelic
experience?
Yes.
Yes,
you can try it.
It's here.
I mean,
you got,
you got some time.
Is it
actually not today.
I have to go to another interview,
but,
but um,
I don't know.
Is it kosher to ask you?
Have you taken psychedelics and gotten
into the tank or of course you'd never
stuff the best for it.
This stuff?
Well this is legal.
That stuff's good.
This one's not.
Oh,
that one.
that one's not legal.
So this one's not legal.
This one's legal.
Okay.
Depends on who you're asking.
But what the key is.
I think,
um,
did get a good baseline of sobriety,
doing it,
doing it sober.
But my favorite is actually edible
marijuana.
I think edible marijuana,
especially high doses,
especially in that complete darkness
environment.
Profound visuals like really bizarre,
strange,
strange visuals and they,
they kind of dance for you in there.
It's really,
really wild.
I think it's the best environment ever
for edible marijuana.
Well,
Dennis could an invocation me in the
immersion tech?
Forget the Ige delight ship.
The immersion.
Would you do if we got you one?
Would you,
do you have room for it?
I don't have room for.
Where are you living these days?
I am living in St Paul,
Minnesota.
Still in Minnesota.
Right.
But I am moving to Canada.
I'm immigrating to Canada.
Damn.
This Donald Trump stuff.
Got you down.
Huh?
Got Me down.
Not participating anymore.
Now that my wife has got her little five
year pension,
she's able to retire.
So she's Canadian.
So she's my ticket out of here.
Nice.
So that's why you moving up there.
I am moving to British Columbia.
You were teaching in Minnesota a part of
the time.
I was teaching at the University of
Minnesota and then I stepped back from
that for a couple of years ago because I
just didn't have time and it was an
adjunct professor position.
So the equation between the amount of
work and the amount of compensation just
didn't make sense for awhile.
I mean I enjoyed it a lot but I,
I've lived in BC a lot.
I'm almost three quarters.
I mean,
you know,
I got my phd at UBC,
my daughter's got dual citizenship and
she's up there now and I love it up
there.
We're going to move.
Fantastic.
You know,
I'm,
I'm excited.
I'm applied for my permanent residence
and there's no,
no reason why I wouldn't get it.
You know,
it's pretty simple a thing.
So that will happen next spring as soon
as we can.
We gotta wait for House,
got to wait for the prime time to sell
our house,
which will be next February.
And also time is the winter end of the
winter,
I would think.
No one's going anywhere and people start
looking at the end of February.
So it's a hot time too because it's a
buy.
It's a seller's market right now.
Oh,
that's great.
We're going to go up there.
What part of BC?
Well,
around Vancouver,
we probably won't be able to afford to
live in Vancouver.
The housing market is utterly nuts,
but somewhere close by white rock,
Abbotsford.
Have you looked at Vancouver island?
Yeah,
we've looked at Vancouver and it's not
that much less expensive there.
It's nice,
but it's logistically it's a problem.
I can go anywhere.
You have to take a ferry.
So I'm looking forward to hold the,
all the work,
all the travel.
I do need to be close to the airport,
but I am excited.
I mean,
for one thing,
uh,
you know,
my colleague Wade Davis is up there,
you know him.
He's the person that wrote one river.
He was a protege of shoulder.
He was a graduate student of shelties.
He's one of the author,
one of the editors on this and very well
known as an ethnobotanist and for years
he was the explorer in residence for the
National Geographic.
He's the guy that worked out the Zombie
poisoned mystery back in the day,
you know,
in Haiti.
Uh,
he's that guy,
but he's written a lot of excellent
books and now he's a Columbian.
Devil's dust or whatever the hell that
is.
No,
no,
that's,
that's broke Vancea.
That's tollway.
No,
this is the Saab beat.
Madison is a tetrodotoxin,
which is a toxin from puffer fish as
well as other other marine sources.
It's a tetrodotoxin.
It's a paralytic,
neurotoxin.
That utterly paralyzes you for about 48
hours.
Whoa.
And,
but you're completely conscious.
You can hear everything.
You can't move a muscle.
And so in the,
in the Zombie context,
they would contrive to,
you know,
give this to people.
If they want to put the whammy on them,
then they would bury them.
Oh Jesus.
And if they were lucky they would.
And then they would assume that like 48
hours later,
and of course a lot of them did die,
but if they were alive then they would
be zombies.
They don't give them a,
a mixture of a detour and other bad
things that would destroy their memory
and completely discombobulate them.
And then they would send them off and
they would spend their life as you know,
sort of wandering around completely,
you know,
shells of their former self.
Wow.
Did the Torah has permanent effects like
that?
It can,
it can.
And after this traumatic experience,
you could imagine,
you know what?
So we'd worked all that out.
His first book was called the serpent
and the rainbow that was made into a
film.
Yeah.
Terrible film,
but good book.
But later he wrote a.
He wrote many books.
His most memorable one is basically a
biography of shelties called the one
river,
one river adventures in the Amazon or
something like that.
He'd be a great guy to bring it on your
show.
It sounds awesome.
Very articulate man.
And you know,
we worked actually this hair collitus
expedition I was telling you on wade was
on that expedition and I've gotten to
know him.
I consider him a good friend,
but he's now.
He's an endowed professor of
anthropology at the University of
British Columbia,
which sounds real stuffy and it is.
But he's not a stuffy guy.
He's got wonderful tales to tell.
Well,
I can guarantee you that there's float
tank centers in Vancouver float tank
centers in Vancouver.
We'll,
we'll get you connected.
Nokia.
You need.
You need this in your life.
I'd love to.
I'd love to get into it.
It's great physically to just,
you feel very relaxed and out of there.
My issue always,
Joe,
is I just never feel like I have time,
but that's my issue as well.
Change my attitude about that.
I realize that I need to take time out
to care for my body.
I don't do enough of that,
you know?
Yeah.
But I'm hoping that when I move up to BC
wait and I can do some work together and
maybe even teach,
you know,
work on this thing in South America,
gets some courses going down there
because with him,
you know,
as one of the faculty that will bring a
lot of people.
I mean he's,
he's high profile and really a good guy.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
So do you have a timeline for this
thing?
Improve a wealth?
It's happening faster than I had dared
to hope actually.
I think,
I mean,
you know,
I hate,
I hate to predict and then not be able
to,
you know,
but my guess is that a year from now
we'll be on the way.
I mean,
it is all happening and this is the
formative year.
We know where we want to go.
We're talking to investors who were
seriously interested.
They want to get involved and they have
money and it's not just about money.
They also have,
you know,
they've listened to the medicine man.
It's all about the medicine as we know,
changes people's hearts and minds.
So these folks,
they have the resources,
but they realize there's a larger vision
and so,
you know,
for me personally what I want to do,
part of my problem is I'm running around
the world all the time and I'm going to
these conferences,
I'm propagating the message and I can't
stop myself.
I have,
yes,
a holism and takes it,
takes a lot out of me and it keeps me
distracted.
So what I want to do if possible is pull
my elbows in a little bit and say,
rather than go to your conference in
Prague or your conference and,
you know,
wherever create this place and make that
a place where people can come and have
really rich experiences,
whether or not they involve
psychedelics,
they can have rich learning experiences.
I mean,
it's perfect location.
Want to learn about the incas.
Machu Picchu is right there,
it's all there.
Um,
and there's just,
it.
I,
I've always liked the idea of platform.
So,
you know,
I want to create a platform.
Well,
catalytic nexus for global consciousness
transformation,
that's the idea.
And do therapeutic programs,
retreats,
impactful conferences like Michael
Pollan level,
Graham Hancock level Joe Rogan level
conferences.
If I could ever convince you to come
down,
which may be will happen,
maybe it will someday and uh,
and just use it as a,
as a platform.
I kind of,
you know,
I liked the academic idea,
use it as a place where we can try to
understand ourselves and our place in
nature better,
you know,
and,
and through plant medicines and clear
thinking and creative people and uh,
and just make it that.
And then I can be like,
you know,
the,
I can be more in residence there and I
don't have to keep running around the
world.
I don't want to say I'm the girl in
residence because my first thing is I
know girl,
I'm just,
I'm just alerting or like everybody else
email.
That's,
we're all,
we're all just curious monkeys,
right?
Yeah.
What seems to me that with psychedelics,
the interest and the desire far exceeds
the access.
Yeah.
Especially in this country,
there's so many people that really have
no idea where to start.
I can't tell you how many people have
asked me,
hey,
how do I get mushrooms?
It's just even amongst people that you
would think would know someone who would
have something,
but it's one of those.
It's one of those things where we're
going to have to wait until things get
more legal until the environment changes
and it seems to be moving in that way.
I think it is,
you know,
John Hopkins doing research and there's
all these different studies that are
being made through maps in particular
and various other organizations are
trying to push this idea of,
especially in the beginning,
working with soldiers,
people with PTSD and showing these
massive results and that to open up
people's minds that there's a bunch of
different things.
MTMA being one of them,
psilocybin being another and then
hopefully eventually we'll work our way
to dmt.
Well,
this is one of the attractions of,
of creativeness platform in the sacred
valley because the whole.
Or in Peru,
because the whole regulatory framework
is different.
You know,
Peru is declared Iowasca national
patrimony and there's no restriction on
the use of Iowaska and all these other
plant medicines are part of a tradition,
you know,
San Pedro called watch,
Houma,
uh,
you know,
the snuffs will snuff.
All of these things can be used without
restriction.
Now I don't know about the status of
mushrooms,
but I think with a little bit of
transparency we could also get
permission.
I mean you could probably use them at
this place and nobody would say a word,
but if we wanted to we could get
permission to use them.
And that's the idea is to not restricted
to Iowasca be able to look at all of
these plant medicines in a very
intelligent way and also bring science
and shamanism together,
you know,
work with smart Shamans who also want to
work with,
with,
with clinicians to develop a really new
paradigm that combines the best of both.
And Michael Paulin refers to this a
little bit,
but he kind of glosses over it.
But I think that's where the,
the therapeutic revolution is going to
come.
When you fuse shamanism and,
and the clinical approach.
And you can do all that there and
develop models that can be used other
places and you don't have to be
secretive about it,
you know,
you don't have to be ashamed or we're
not doing anything illegal or covert.
And so again,
we can,
uh,
you know,
rather than being sort of,
uh,
what we can shout it from the rooftops,
we want to,
not that we necessarily would do that,
but it can be open about what we're
doing.
There are also a lot of good,
there are a lot of smart people in Peru
and smart doctors and so on,
smart clinicians.
So we want to involve local communities,
local people as much as possible and
then expand that to all the other things
that this relates to like,
like sustainable agriculture.
And it's a perfect place to look at,
you know,
new paradigms for food production and so
on.
The Sacred Valley is one of the five
areas in the world where agriculture
originated.
You know,
most of our important food plants came
from there.
Originally they have 6,000
varieties of potatoes for thousand
varieties of tomatoes.
I mean really incredible food,
bio diversity and the foods that have
gone global,
how many varieties of potatoes doc in
the,
in the grocery store,
maybe four or five at most.
So there is an incredible genetic
repository of these things that have
never really been developed on a global
scale and a lot of them,
that's our part of the solution to the
food crisis that we face.
And also what the incas knew about
agriculture is it was pretty
revolutionary.
So there's the,
you know,
the spectrum is broad.
Are you going to have a standardized
ingredients list when it comes to like
Iowasca?
Like in terms of like the dosage that's
work that we want to do?
Yeah.
I'm not necessarily to impose it on
other people,
but I think I think it could benefit
from a bit of analytical work.
I'd like,
I'd like to do that.
I'm also interested in the,
uh,
the sort of the Pharmacopia of other
plants that,
that are associated with Iowasca.
They're not put into Iowasca all the
time,
but they're there.
Sometimes they use for the [inaudible],
there's a whole pharmacopia plants not
very well investigated that I'd like to
look more deeply into and maybe even
develop formulations of Iowasca with
some of these other plants that could be
used for more specific therapeutic
purposes.
So you might have one that's good for
say ptsd and one that's better for
depression and you know,
you could actually tailor these things,
bring a little science into it because
you know,
and,
and you don't have to have a lot,
you know,
you don't have to have gleaming
laboratories for this.
You can do it with a very simple setup,
simple natural products.
Laboratory,
most importantly is the people that you
have in there,
not the equipment that you have.
And you could do a lot of stuff.
And partly this is what this book is
about to the Ethno pharmacologic search
for psychoactive drugs.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
a lot of what's in this book is,
is talking about the Iowaska and Peyote
and things that we know about.
Um,
but talking about it in ways that we've
never looked at it before,
and then there is a whole bunch of
things out there that really,
I mean,
there's a great future for discovery
things we've never heard of,
you know,
and that's what ethno pharmacology is
about.
And specifically it's the ethno
pharmacology search for a psychoactive
drugs.
So there's a lot still to be discovered.
Now.
Canada has just recently legalized
marijuana as of today.
Yes.
Yeah.
Did they have any plans or do you know
of considering the legality of other
substances?
As a matter of fact,
they do.
Um,
there is,
there,
I can't really talk about it.
Actually,
I shouldn't talk about it because I
don't have that much information.
But there is a gentleman who came to one
of my retreats.
I meet the most interesting people.
If these retreats,
you wouldn't believe it.
This guy is a,
a of aspiring young politician,
Canadian politician from Ottawa.
He's talking to Justin about legalizing
psychedelics for therapeutic uses and
he's,
you know,
working with some,
some lawyers and so on and putting
together a proposal to do this.
Mtma assisted psychotherapy trials begin
final phase in Vancouver.
Well,
there you go.
But that's maps,
right?
That's the catalyst behind that.
He wants to change policy.
And the thing is the Canadians are
reasonable people.
That's the big difference from
Americans.
You know,
you can propose this kind of thing and
they'll,
they won't dismiss it out of hand,
lol,
you know,
what's your evidence?
Why should we do this?
So Justin's a very young guy,
he's young and I imagine he's been
beyond the chrysanthemum a time or two.
I do.
Really?
Sure.
I think so.
Wow.
What makes you say that?
Because he's spoken about it.
I'm sure he wouldn't speak about it.
I guess just to guess he's the right
age.
Um,
he,
while I can't say it's just pure
speculation,
let's put it this way,
I,
I wouldn't be surprised for people that
don't know what we're talking about.
Beyond the Cassandra means there's this
thing that you see when you break
through and you do dmt that's very
bizarre.
Geometric pattern that resembles a Santa
Mum.
Right?
Right.
You know,
the,
the Canadians,
I mean,
for instance,
to get approval for these Mtma trolls
was a lot more straightforward in
Canada,
you know,
and uh,
now and,
and they've done some clinical studies
with Iowasca and they're,
they're board with that.
Uh,
they've done some studies with
indigenous people in Canada.
They call it first nations,
but they have,
they have done that and it's been
pretty.
It's been straightforward to get that
work done.
That would be drug hysteria that we
have,
you know.
So I think it's a good place to produce,
pursue this research.
Well,
in many ways they were victims of our
jug hysteria.
I,
and they sort
of adopted our ideas,
right?
I'll be interested to see our response
to the legalization of cannabis.
That's gonna piss them off.
Well,
it'll piss off that little elf sessions
right now,
but I,
a just great team needs to be pissed
off.
He's such a fool that guy,
this statement,
good people don't smoke marijuana.
That is one of the dumbest fucking
things anyone has ever said ever.
It's such a crazy thing to say like that
is one of the dumbest generalizations,
you know,
that's like saying all white people are
evil.
It's like it's just so stupid.
It's just stupid thing to say.
Just a stupid thing to say.
This idea that we could go right across
the border to Vancouver and experience,
you know,
the host of the psychedelic experiences
would be.
I mean,
that would be fantastic and I do it
equally.
I tanked it.
You'll,
you'll see that very soon.
That would be amazing and I just hope it
would have a positive effect on,
you know,
our country.
I just.
It doesn't make any sense.
When you think about how many troops
come back over from overseas with these
traumatic experiences and ptsd and real
issue psychologically in that the number
one tool for handling this,
it's not,
it's not psychotherapy.
The number one tool of psychedelics.
It's the best in terms of efficacy,
in terms of proven results.
There's nothing that's even remotely
close.
Whether it's true Mtma or psilocybin or
any of these psychedelic therapies.
They have profound effects when it comes
to the ability to disconnect from
addictive behaviors,
particularly drugs,
opiates.
There's nothing better than these
psychedelic experiences particular
Ibogaine and you know,
you got to go to Mexico to go to t to
use Ibogaine,
you know,
and I think within five years you're
gonna see clinic sad and maybe even
centers,
you know,
along the lines of what we're talking
about.
A know in the sacred valley.
I mean,
once you've done something like this,
then you can replicate it in different
countries where,
where the regulatory environment is
friendly.
So you could have,
you know,
we have the Mckenna Academy and in Peru,
but then we have brand,
you know,
if they meet the standards then we can
essentially licensed south that brand or
whatever.
And then you could potentially do one in
Vancouver.
Of course.
Yeah.
That would be sensational.
You know,
dude,
I'll help.
I swear to God.
I'll go over there.
I love Vancouver.
I go there every chance I can.
Well that's good.
So maybe I'll see you more often when.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
for sure.
I still have to drag you to South
America all I know.
I'll get you.
I'll get you one.
I have young kids and I'm always busy
and I travel too much as it is.
It's a grind to get me out of the
content of the answer to that.
What does that bring your wife and kids
to Peru to parade
around a bunch of hippies.
Now we have a perfect place.
You know we can take care of the kids.
There's a catch.
You have a family that runs one of the
senators and they would love to take
care of your kids.
Your wife can do yoga.
It's or whatever she wants to do.
I like how you say the wife could do
yoga.
She's not going to trip to.
Of course she get mad.
No,
she wants to track.
Of course you could do it.
Somebodies got to watch the kids though.
Turtle.
That's what I say.
There are people who love kids and
they'll be happy to Babysit,
but it'll happen when the time is.
The
positive benefits are so overwhelming
and the evidence is so clear and so many
people have these incredibly powerful
experiences that they're relaying to
other people and oftentimes it's people
that are there like the people with the
closed minds,
maybe their loved ones have had these
experiences and maybe their loved ones
were really far gone and have come back
and they can see these results and
recognize that,
especially when it comes to,
in my opinion,
veterans,
we have an overwhelming responsibility
to take care of those people that we
don't meet.
We don't meet it medically,
we don't meet it psychologically.
We don't meet it with therapy.
We just don't give them enough.
They don't.
We don't meet it financially and this
could be a way to heal them to help help
them reconcile their experience and help
them achieve balance back here,
you know,
state side of.
It's not just,
it's not just veterans that are
traumatized.
All kinds of people are sure.
Ties.
Yes.
In fact,
everybody is traumatized with certain
extent just by living in this society.
I mean,
we are a wounded society.
Yes.
That's the thing I think,
you know,
I think psychedelics are medicines for,
for the soul in a sense and medicines
for our species in a certain sense.
I mean that's why they're global,
you know,
we're a wounded society and we're,
and it's dysfunctionality is now
becoming a parent,
you know,
through the political situations.
I mean,
I,
I am just baffled by a,
you know,
a government of president who basically
likes to hurt people.
I mean that,
that seems to be it.
It's this culture of cruelty,
cruelty that has been,
that has been created and a,
well,
particularly if he feels slighted,
you know,
he wants to come back at you extra hard.
Yeah.
And it's a reflection of probably of his
childhood trauma.
I mean,
I think his father was very abusive.
Now he's,
it's his chance to get revenge,
you know,
and I mean,
he's the guy.
Kim,
what's that?
When you love to take him for a trip,
you know,
I don't think it would do any good,
really.
I don't think it would do any good.
Why not?
Because I don't think there's a moral.
I don't think there's was a core there,
you,
my,
uh,
I mean I would certainly,
I don't think it would help him.
Look,
Karen,
Daryl enforced work most with said,
told me,
you know,
there are two kinds of people I will not
give Iowasca to.
One is sociopath's and the other is
schizophrenia.
Trump is a sociopath.
He has no interior.
He's never had a reflective moment in
this life.
That's what concerns me.
It's all external,
you know,
he's like pure id,
he is a,
a six year old,
an angry.
If we met him at 16,
would you have hope for his future?
How do you.
I mean,
when as a person,
beyond reproach or beyond help.
Like what,
what is the year?
So we have this idea in our minds that
when a certain age is reached that a
person is just firmly established and
there's no more growth.
No,
no.
You see someone who's a 60 year old
fool,
that's a dying fool.
He's going to be a full till his last
day on this planet.
Why is that though?
Why don't we just assume that someone
lives a certain life?
Has a certain amount of time here that
they're not going to learn.
Is it just because of our own past
experiences with these types of people
or are we imposing a limitation on their
growth?
I'm very curious about that because we
do do that.
We assume that if someone fucks up and
they're 20 will,
they'll get better,
they'll,
they're going to evolve if they fuck up
when they're 70,
were like,
that guy's a goner.
Well,
we make that assumption,
you know,
and it may not be true.
I mean,
not fair.
I don't think the way it's not fair.
Um,
I mean,
especially now what we're learning.
Um,
the other thing that psychedelics do
that is a kind of a new thing that we're
learning is neuroplasticity.
Yes.
It actually reorganizes connections in
the brain.
You know,
psilocybin does this and presumably the
others,
the others do to,
some of the Fed means do it.
So that's a new thing,
you know,
you can actually change the conductivity
of the systems.
That's probably not fair to say.
I mean,
my friend who came with me,
he,
he made a point when we were discussing
this.
He says,
you know,
you shouldn't hate trump,
he's used to that.
You should love trump.
I said,
it's real hard for me to love trump,
but I think the point that he's making
is that he is.
Trump is not the cause of it in some
way.
He's the,
he's the symptom of,
of what's happening and he's,
he's the disruptor.
But the disruption is happening anyway.
And,
and so in some ways maybe we should be
grateful to trump because he's,
he's making,
you know,
he's,
he's making it so in everybody's face
that,
that people are questioning everything
and that's,
that's a good thing because the system,
it can't last,
you know.
So there's gonna be a transition that's
going to be pretty rough and trump is
just part of that.
Not In any conscious way.
He's as much the victim of the Times as
anybody else and have expectation that
has,
be president,
has his finger on the nuclear button and
a few other inconvenient things.
Otherwise he would just be dismissed.
You know,
it was an old cranky old guy.
The television was fun before this,
I guess.
Yeah,
I mean,
before this,
he was your fired.
You know,
he was the rich guy with his name on the
big buildings.
He was a caricature.
You know,
he wasn't.
It wasn't what he is now.
What he is now is he's show.
He's exploited this vulnerability and
the political system that we essentially
a popularity contest that choose our
rulers and the idea of that and at first
was to pick the best one based on public
perception,
but that's not what it is anymore.
Now it's like we are so jaded as to how
well this system works and as to what
significant and important about it and
we just want our guy to win.
Now it's our guy and Hillary.
Hillary represented the bureaucrats.
She represented the red tape and the
career politicians,
the one,
the proven liars,
the ones who were starting these Clinton
foundations and making hundreds of
millions of dollars and giving these
speeches and making hundreds of
thousands of dollars talking to bankers
but won't release any of the
transcripts.
And enough we've got to drain the swamp.
And this guy was our guy to drain the
swamp.
The private voted for him,
you know,
and this is,
um.
Then he came on and it turns out he is,
the swamp is in escapable system is
completely broken.
I mean,
I certainly don't think if we elected
hillary,
it would all be good.
It would still be a mess.
But the problem with trump is he's
immune to facts for one thing.
And they,
I mean,
the man is obviously diluted,
possibly demented,
certainly a social path.
I mean,
and,
and very impulsive.
And this is not.
You need,
you know,
this is not the person you need to be
leading the western world because.
Because he's not reflective,
he's not.
It's all response.
You know,
this is,
this is the petula six year old aspect
of it.
He sees something and he reacts
immediately.
There's no thought that intervenes and
he's often said that about his business
deals.
He doesn't plan things.
He just goes into nozstock great.
A businessman,
if you look back on,
if you look at his business deals,
that's the same with Korea thing.
I mean if he can pull that off,
more power to him,
but I'll bet you it's not going to go
anywhere.
[inaudible],
you know Kim Shannon and the Chinese who
are behind it,
they are very smart and they.
They basically realized this guy is a
buffoon and they will be able to make a
show on the world stage,
but they won't give up anything and
people are already saying this.
What did he actually come away with?
Nothing.
Some vague mumblings about
denuclearization.
We've had that before,
but it was
unprecedented to see the leader of North
Korea and South Korea meet at the DMZ
and shake hands and trap was traveled
that precedent.
That was pretty fascinating.
That was pretty fast.
I think that's progress in some way and
maybe his lunacy needs leads to
inadvertent progress or advert.
I mean,
maybe it's some sort of,
he's,
people are many things.
He can't be entirely foolish.
There's probably a method to is matt,
he never lost all of his money.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
he really hasn't been at least
marginally success.
Success has gone bankrupt a few times,
but the point is that this is a guy
that,
um,
he's probably pretty complex as much as
he is crazy.
It's probably also pretty complex and
some of that might benefit us because we
have this fucked up system that's
undeniably fucked up.
It says it's just a terrible idea
though.
And it was a idea that was constructed
in 1776 when it made sense back then.
It was a great solution to the problems
of the times.
But we don't live in those times.
No,
we don't live in those times.
Mainly complicated times.
And also we didn't have the media
situation that we have now.
I mean,
this,
this is also part of the problem,
you know,
with the social media and everything.
It's true.
There's puns of fake news out there
produced on both.
You cannot tell.
So you've got the trump a reality
distortion field,
right?
Which is reinforced by his really no
pretense about ignoring what's real,
you know,
like this whole controversy about,
about the immigration and splitting up
families and say,
well we're just enforcing the law.
But in fact,
you know,
at the stroke of a pen he could change
that and we didn't enforce that way
before.
But.
So he's changed that,
you know,
just changed,
just caved in and now he's,
yeah,
he supposedly.
But it's nice at least that he's doing
that,
like listening to public opinion in the
outcries reached him and he's reacted
yell,
but this is my car.
It's not that he cares about these
children or,
or you know,
how many people has he already
traumatized as a result of this?
But,
you know,
I'm glad that he changed it,
but I'm sure that was a cynical
decision.
Has Advisors said,
look,
Look Donald,
you know,
you're about to go to a.
you're about to go to a rally in Duluth.
I honestly think it's coming from
certain.
Not gonna like this.
I think it's coming from his wife.
Is this going around to this a jacket
she wore to a
uh.
Oh,
what she say it says,
I really don't care.
Do you?
Yeah,
and this was a meeting of diy.
Like immigration.
Yeah.
Kids.
She's been the kids.
Yeah.
What is that?
Is that.
But is that in some fashion jacket that
she wore to that event?
What a stupid fucking thing to where I
really don't care.
Do you care?
Yeah,
I do care.
But what are you talking about?
What a bizarre,
open ended question.
I really don't care about the tone
deafness of these people.
They know sensitivity critic though of
separating children from their families
and she actually made a surprise visit
to the Mexican border today to check on
it.
See what's going on.
Good for her.
Good.
Well,
she's an immigrant.
I mean this is the irony of the whole
thing.
She barely speaks English.
The whole thing is so bizarre is that
his own wife is a fucking immigrant.
I mean clearly the whole thing is crazy.
It's really strange.
But that jacket,
this what?
This is the sign of the simulation if
you considered the simulation theory.
Yes.
Thank you.
Real real might be real.
I mean sometimes I do wonder.
I mean it's like it's like reality.
Whatever we choose to call it is
becoming so weird that I often ask
myself,
who is writing this shit and can't they
get a better writer?
You know?
I mean,
look,
this is so absurd.
And yet I began actively considering it
when congressmen wiener kept pulling his
dick out this,
it's just crazy.
That guy.
I'm like,
this is too much.
And then when trump won,
I just was sitting down going,
imagine if we,
one day someone shuts it off and the
lights dim and then they turned back on
and you realize,
well,
the game's over.
How did you like it?
And you're like,
what?
That was fake.
Yeah,
you,
you just went and it only took an hour.
How long did it seem?
Like 50 years.
You know,
and yeah,
you,
you've,
you're in a simulation with artificial
memories implanted into your mind.
Well,
the one day that the idea that there's
going to be an artificial reality or
virtual reality,
that's so good that it's
indistinguishable.
I mean,
this is almost inevitable if technology
increases at the same rate that it's
increasing now,
whether it's two years from now or 100
years from now,
we're going to reach some point in time.
So the real question is
when we do reach that,
how will we know?
Well,
what if we're already there for the use
of simulation?
How would we know and how we test it.
We test it,
do you.
But another aspect of this is,
do we really want this?
You know,
do I mean,
do we want to be immersed in a virtual
reality?
Even if we could produce one so
sophisticated,
we couldn't tell it from,
from whatever this is,
this,
let's assume for the moment this is
reality.
It stops it.
Do we want to migrate into a virtual
reality?
My concern,
my real concern is that we are the last
wave of the biological human.
I'm,
I'm really,
uh,
really do believe this.
I'm concerned about that too.
I'm not sure.
I think that that's a good thing.
I don't necessarily think it's a good
thing for the biological human,
but I,
I feel like if you separate yourself
from the idea of good and bad in the
inevitability of innovation and
progress,
it's human beings continue to make more
and more complex electronics with higher
and higher capabilities.
It's inevitable that we become symbiotic
with these things that we ingrain them
into our.
They're going to become a part of your
body.
We're going to replace body parts with
more efficient body parts and we are one
day going to create some sort of
artificial life.
Now whether we become a part of that
artificial life,
we merged with it or it just assumes the
role of the leader of the earth.
One of those things is likely to happen
within the next 500 years.
It's just.
And that's,
that's a really generous timeframe.
I think that's
generous timeframe.
Yeah.
Well,
you know this,
this.
I mean,
in some ways this is sort of.
This raises the issue about,
you know,
one of the things that psychedelics put
in front of us front and center is the
fact that we are getting a strange from
nature.
You know,
that's the main lesson were getting this
strange from nature.
We have to really understand our
relationship and,
and um,
you know,
become a partner that's in the symbiosis
with nature and this projection is the
exact opposite of that.
So is that,
you know,
so maybe you know,
this,
this raises also in one issue that we
haven't really touched on,
but here,
but you know,
technology,
which is what this virtual reality stuff
is and what any artifact is psychedelics
or technology.
Molecular biology is technology.
Cybernetics as technology technology
inherently has no moral dimension.
You know,
these are not good or bad things,
you know,
the way that they are used by humans,
the decisions that humans make in the
way that they're going to exploit or
deploy these technologies.
That's where the moral dimension comes
in.
Morality comes out of the human heart.
You know,
and we are one of our problems,
I feel as a species.
We're extremely clever,
but we're not wise.
That's what it is.
We're not wise about what we do.
We're not able to step back and say,
well,
yeah,
we can produce,
we can,
you know,
download the brain into cybernetics or
we can produce an artificial body or we
can do all this genetic stuff.
Do we ever stopped to think about just
because we can something,
should we do something,
you know?
Uh,
we,
uh,
and the arrogance of science.
This is also a problem.
The scientists will say,
well,
they are scientists,
right?
We can do it.
So let's do it.
We can do the Hadron experiment and
maybe it'll collapse,
collapsed the space time continuum,
but the very small probability.
So let's do it,
right?
Yeah.
And that's something we have to learn.
I think also the psychedelics are
important in that regard too.
They are ways that we can bring our
cleverness and our wisdom into sync so
that we have the wisdom not to do
something even though we might be able
to,
we shouldn't do it just because we can
do it,
you know,
we really have to as a species,
ask ourselves is this a good idea?
And I think again,
these psychedelics are teaching tools
for learning this and really propagating
the message from the
community of species.
That's for sure.
Going to be a meme with a photo of your
face that we are very clever but we're
not wise.
That's for sure.
Going to be a meme.
Some,
some dude or gal is working on that
right now.
Well,
I've been talking about this sentence
so,
so striking not my real concern with
this stuff is that this is inevitable
and this is just like the single celled
organism became the multicell organism
and that the thinking,
curious monkey who strives for material
possessions is designed to create
artificial life.
And this is just what we've said here.
I've described it as that we are the
technological butterfly that will emerge
from the cocoon and right now we're
creating this cocoon that we are this
caterpillar,
yeah,
technological caterpillar,
and we don't know why we're making this
cocoon and that we are going to give
birth,
this artificial life,
this next stage of complexity that may
be true
to.
I mean,
what you say is true.
You know,
on some level,
anything that can be done is going to be
dumb.
Somebody's gonna do it,
but so,
you know,
is it good?
Is it good?
Is it good for the collective?
I mean,
you know,
they're always megalomaniacs will say,
well,
I can do it.
I can start a nuclear war,
so why don't we do this?
You know,
that's,
that's the tricky part.
Again,
I think,
you know,
psychedelics are important in giving us
a moral compass.
I mean,
wisdom not,
not a set of rules about that come out
of the religious perception.
A set of rules that come out of the
biological perception.
What is most compatible?
What is most nourishing,
nourishing for living?
Things presumably don't want to trash
this planet.
You know,
we now have the ability to do that,
you know,
the forces that we can manipulate for
the first time in history pose a real
possibility that we could and life on
earth.
I think it's hard,
but I think we may be able to do it.
Am I for one,
don't want to see that happen.
I had a bit a few years back in my
comedy act about the origins of the
universe and that what happens is people
get so smart that they develop a big
bang machine and that someone's sitting
around and some guy who's on the autism
spectrum was filled up with SSRI
antidepressants and drinking red bull
all day.
He just goes,
fuck it.
I'll press it and he hits the button and
boom,
we start from scratch and then every,
you know,
14 plus billion years,
someone develops the big bang machine
and hits it and that's the restart of
the universe over and over with this
idea of the universal simulation.
I am,
I am.
In some ways it's possible.
I mean,
it's possible.
It is.
Well,
it's inevitable that there will be
simulated worlds,
right?
I'm not necessarily completely obsessed
with the idea that we're living in a
simulation,
but I am completely obsessed that we are
a relic and that we are on our way out.
I really am.
I really do think that maybe that's one
of the reasons why we're so crazy and so
haywire.
It's just shows.
There's no logical progression for our
culture that it's as advanced as we are,
as much access to information as we
have.
We're also as crazy as we have ever
been,
if not crazier.
Yeah.
So the age of low curious monkey is
coming to a close
wonder how much of a limitation our
biology is too.
I mean,
you think about what it took to get to
here and all the battles we had to fight
and the animals we had to run from and
all these human reward systems that are
ingrained into our DNA and that now here
we are in a place where we hardly need
them and yet we still have them just
blowing up and exploding and vomiting
all over the place and these weird ways
and we have them sort of manifesting
themselves in very strange behaviors
that aren't,
aren't good for anybody and this
constant need to acquire material
possessions and conquer and and,
and obtain things at.
This is,
this is not tenable.
This is not something that makes sense
in the long haul,
but yet we still go down this illogical
road and that this is really just
because this is the best way to fuel
innovation,
are extreme desire for material
possessions is the best way to ensure
that they're gonna keep coming up with
newer,
better things every year which will
eventually give birth to the electronic
butterfly.
Well,
I don't know what to say about it.
I mean it may be.
That may be where we're,
where we're headed and you know,
it may be that this isn't necessary to.
I mean if,
if our destiny is to actually leave the
earth at some point,
if,
if the earth is an incubator for life
and we're just destined to leave it and
spread out into the galaxy and beyond,
who knows?
I mean,
then maybe this is inevitable that we
have to,
that we have to do that if that's what's
happening.
But the question is what kind of being
will we be when we do that?
You know,
we won't be human.
It will be something different than
humans.
That's what I've always wondered about
the alien archetype,
that big headed thing with the no
genitals and no mouth.
That may be what we think of as being
the ultimate form that the human animal
tanks.
If when we do,
if we do symbiotically merged with
technology and electronics at that might
be the form that we.
It's just so strange at that one
excepted form,
and I've heard,
I've heard the idea that this,
this image is something when young eyes
from a newborn baby sees a doctor and
see the doctor with the mask and the
face and this is what they see and that
this is imprinted in our mind,
this traumatic experience of the birth
and the bright lights and the operating
table.
This is why so many of these alien
abduction experiences do take place in
these very clinic clinical sterile
environments and it seems like a medical
procedure as if this is a remnant of the
birth process.
I've heard that experience.
I've heard that explanation,
but it also.
It strikes me that these things are.
There you go,
you go from ancient hominids,
you go from Australia,
Pythagoras,
and then you go to a modern computer
programmer who doesn't exercise and you
look at their body.
This sort of like doughy thin bodied.
It doesn't move very well and then you
go back to this muscular apelike
creature that's covered in hair.
They've lost all the hair,
they've lost all the muscle.
They become thin and then where's that
going?
Well,
it's obviously going in that same
direction.
It's not going to.
People are not going to get more
muscular and harder and hairier as time
goes on unless something radical changes
and we need to adapt.
Right.
So that would be the normal.
I mean the path would.
That would be the natural progression
that we would eventually have bigger
heads because we have bigger heads in
Australia,
pithy kiss and certainly bigger heads
than chimps are,
but no elbows.
He just keeps going in that same
direction.
Hello?
Possibly.
Or maybe we just leave the biological
shell behind,
but then whereas I'm really shocked.
I mean what do we are transhuman and we.
No,
I'm,
I'm not sure I want to go there.
I don't think I want to go there,
but I'm,
I'm.
But I'm thinking is like what is,
what is it that's making me clean to
these ideas?
Is it that I love emotions.
I love illogical behavior.
Do I love art?
Yeah.
I love all those things.
I love music and food and all the things
that cooking and all the things that
make a person a person camaraderie,
but what are those things are those
chemical reactions we have with other
beings and natural reward systems that
are built in to sort of enhanced
community and comradery so that we can
stay together so the species survives
and like what if there's something that
supplants that?
What if there's something that far
surpasses that in terms of pleasure and
connectivity and we realized that
emotions are just these,
these ancient systems that were put into
place when there wasn't a better option
with these better options.
It's much better to get your food from a
supermarket than it is to chase down a
gazelle for two days until it dies of
heatstroke.
You know what I mean?
These,
these systems improve over time.
You know,
this,
um,
this animal that we are now is very
different than the animal we used to be.
Why do we want to stay in this imperfect
state that seems even more ridiculous,
that would like to stay humans forever.
Humans are so flawed.
We have been.
There's a reason why we have all this
nonsense in the world and our society is
sick and we are twisted and confused,
but a part of it at least has to be that
the human animal itself is very flawed
because there's no perfect culture.
You can't just chalk it up to culture
because if you did chalk it up to
culture,
you would say,
well,
this culture sucks,
but if you go to this culture,
it's amazing.
There's no crime.
Everyone loves everyone.
It's completely open.
There's no need to worry about money
because everybody's generous and and
everything gets and they're really
brilliant and they get along and they
create new architecture and everything's
fantastic.
It's the perfect society that doesn't
exist,
but is that the culture that we can
create with the help of psychedelics?
Is that what we're shooting for now or
humans truly humanistic culture where
people were love is what's happening
where it's driven by love,
not by hatred and rivalry and scarcity
and fear,
you know,
and that's the whole thing.
The psychedelics can be the catalyst
that teaches us how to love ourselves,
how to love each other.
I love the earth,
I mean,
I know that sounds cliche and trivial,
but that track,
that is in fact what the promise that
they hold for us.
That's why they're teachers.
They're teaching learning tools.
They can teach us to be
the human beings
that we would like to be,
you know,
and,
and I,
and that's the thing,
that's,
that's the alternative to this hyper
technological future,
you know,
and uh,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm all for technology.
I'm not against technology,
but again,
I think we have to,
you don't have to.
We have bring wisdom to it.
We have to make a situation where,
you know,
it is not controlling us.
We are controlling it and we're thinking
clearly about we have,
you know,
this enormous panoply of technologies
that can do so many things.
We have to think about how do we deploy
those in such a way to maximize human
potential or you know,
our humanity.
So that's really,
I think what the promise that
psychedelics hold out.
And that's,
you know,
that's what we're hoping to create the,
as a colonel and we're not the only
ones.
Obviously a lot of people have this idea
and it's happening,
but that's the idea is to create a place
where people couldn't learn this and you
know,
and uh,
that's my hope for the future of
humanity.
Well,
it's great hope for the future that
people that are alive today and I think
that's the most important.
We don't know what's coming,
but we do know it's here and I think
that's a great hope for what's here.
And if we don't do it pretty soon there
won't be anybody alive to worry about
it.
I mean this is,
this is the problem.
So the best way to end this I think
possible.
Okay.
So great.
Great Talk.
Thank you.
I always appreciate you coming here,
man.
F No pharmacologic search for
psychoactive drugs.
Two volumes,
1967 and volume two,
2017,
50 years available.
Where can people get it?
Can get on Amazon and synergetic press.
You can get Amazon,
but synergetic press,
synergenic,
press.
Anything else to tell people about that
you've got going on?
I think we've pretty well covered it.
You know,
I will send you the links to the videos
which are open access to all these
lectures so folks can watch them.
Fantastic.
If they want.
Beautiful.
You can.
Yeah.
All right.
Always a pleasure.
Always a pleasure,
Dennis.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Dennis Mckenna.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you.
That was great.